MonkaW
Easy.
So.
Tut's.
Ja, geht.
Nice.
Und Leute.
Habt ihr gut geschlafen.
Was?
Pogass?
Also,
von mir ging es heute eigentlich.
Ich bin irgendwie 2-3 Mal aufgewacht,
habe aufs Handy geguckt, was eigentlich total bescheuert ist,
weil wenn du aufs Handy guckst, bist du eher noch wacher davon.
Stunde wurde zurückgesetzt.
Ach so.
Moment.
Warte mal.
Chat, Chat.
Wenn die Stunde zurückgesetzt wurde,
heißt das jetzt, die Nacht war länger?
Ja, oder?
Es gab quasi eine Stunde länger heute Nacht.
Das heißt, wenn ich um 8 aufgestanden bin,
dann ist eigentlich
dann ist eigentlich 9
so ne
ok
ah ja
das kam ja auch so lang vor irgendwie
wann wird denn die Uhr zurückgestellt
ich glaube um 2 ja
2 Uhr nachts
2 auf 3 oder irgendwie so
so mitten in der Nacht
Abends wird es früher dunkel, ja das sagt
Ob es morgen hell oder dunkel ist, juckt mich nicht
Aber
Abends früher dunkel ist halt doof
Gerade wenn man arbeiten geht, da ist man halt
sagen wir mal, bis mindestens
eigentlich, mindestens,
ja, 15 Uhr beschäftigt.
Aber eher 15.30, 16 Uhr.
Für alle, die ins Büro
fahren müssen, die müssen ja dann auch heim
fahren.
Und dann ist ja eigentlich schon fast dunkel, wenn du
heim kommst.
Und es wird immer dunkler.
Und ich gehe ja ganz gerne
abends noch mal eine Runde rennen.
Und das
finde ich viel nicer, wenn es dann
auch ein bisschen hell ist, als wenn es schon
dämmerig
oder dunkel ist.
Zumal wirst du dann auch
weniger schnell überfahren von irgendeinem,
der nicht richtig guckt.
By the way,
ich mach mal kurz meine 4M an.
Package Updates.
Arch, by the way.
Wartet nix.
Um erneuerste Packages zu installieren.
Boah, das haben wir gestern schon gemacht.
Egal, aber das Art-Shelungs, da gibt es garantiert wieder neue Updates.
24 Stunden ohne Package-Updates.
Was ist das? Das ist mir nicht Bleeding Edge genug.
Ja.
Gucken wir mal.
Pac-Man.
Stark.
Immerhin.
Immerhin ein paar Updates gibt es.
Weiß.
Gibt es hier vielleicht Package Updates?
Moment.
Wird das...
Wird das Arch User Repo wieder gedodost?
Was ist da los?
Gibt es gibt es wieder auch die DOS Geschichten
Oder ist
TLS handshake timeout ja kann das sein dass das wieder gedelost wird
Das ist sonst recht selten.
Gucken wir mal, ob es Jetbrain-Updates gibt.
Aber hatten wir eigentlich schon gestern.
Gibt es nicht.
Okay, Reboot.
Wobei, warum reboot ich eigentlich?
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich muss gar nicht rebooten.
Es gab kein Kernel-Update.
Egal, Hauptsache reboot.
Und zack.
Zack, zack, zack.
Da sind wir wieder.
Ich mach mal kurz eins, eine Stufe leiser.
So.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal.
Ah, da sind wir wieder.
Nice.
Pepo ist am Frühstück.
Das ist ein gutes Ding.
Ich muss mal was trinken.
so und jetzt gucken wir doch mal wenn wir gerade schon hier sind gucken wir mal was
auf github denn alles so tani vorher vorher war was anderes wahrscheinlich hat der eine
andere schon bei mir auf twitter gelesen aber ich habe letztens die so also ich
glaube ich habe selten so eine all in one stellenanzeige gesehen habe ich auf
reddit gesehen habt ihr mal nachgeguckt ob die echt ist und die war echt aber
die wir mal auf mit geht mit eigentlich wieder ich glaube mit hat mit geht wieder
oder
Nitter, ja.
FPS.
Äh, Users.
Komm mal hier.
Von welcher Firma war die?
Von Fischer.
Das sind die, die die Dübel herstellen.
Fischer Düblors.
Wir können die nochmal aufmachen.
Moment, wo habe ich die?
Jobs Arbeitsagentur.
Wir können mal reingucken.
Jobs Arbeitsagentur Fischer.
Guck mal, ob wir die noch finden.
Was können wir da suchen?
Du hast Spaß suchen wir.
Du hast Spaß.
Okay.
Du passt bestehende Anwendung.
Ich muss.
Ja, da ist er doch.
Alle Cookies ablehnen.
System und Netzwerk Administrator.
MWD Standard übergreifend.
Fischer Automation.
Moment, sind das, sind das, ne, bevor ich jetzt Mist erzählt habe, sind die das mit den Dübeln überhaupt?
Wollt eigentlich.
Fischer Automation GmbH, nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle.
Ne, das sind die gar nicht mit den Dübeln, oder?
Ne, das sind die, das sind die gar nicht.
Sind andere.
Oder?
Das sind die hier.
Oder vielleicht sind das die doch mit den Dübeln.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, wir können uns das...
Vielleicht wurde das Ding ja aktualisiert.
Vor zwölf Tagen bearbeitet.
Nee, wurde nicht aktualisiert.
So, die suchen einen System- und Netzwerkadministrator.
Das ist schon mal komisch.
das in einem, aber gut, bei kleinen
Läden kommt das ja öfters vor, wobei
ich bezweifle, dass die so klein sind,
ja.
So, lasst uns das mal kurz zusammen
angucken. Ich hab nur drüber gescrollt
bisher.
Du möchtest in einem aufstrebenden Unternehmen
mit, okay, bla bla bla bla bla bla
Erwarte dich sowohl
klassische Systemadministration als auch
moderne Softwareentwicklung Webtechnologien.
Die meinen damit, das musst du alles machen.
Nicht, das gibt's.
Nein, das musst du alles machen.
Also das scheint jetzt kein allzu kleiner Laden zu sein.
Nutze deine Chance.
Okay, hier, hier, jetzt geht's los.
Gucken.
Ne, das ist...
also jetzt geht es du bist allein verantwortlich also hört sich so an als bist du der einzige
admin ist da irgendwie gibt du bist allein verantwortlich für die administration weiter
entwicklung und pflege das server intrakt infrastruktur linux und windows das das lasse
ich mir noch irgendwie gefallen ja wenn die da irgendwie was was ich eine windows kiste stehen
haben und drei Linux-Kissen,
das ist ja irgendwie noch überschaubar.
In der Regel ist es so, also wenn
es mehrere Sachen gibt und wenn die Firma
auch ein bisschen größer ist, dann gibt's
eigentlich Leute, die
Schwerpunkt auf Linux haben und Leute,
die Schwerpunkt auf Windows haben. Das liegt
einfach daran, weil
das habe ich auch persönlich schon gemerkt,
dass Leute,
die gut Windows können, wenig
Bock auf Linux haben, wobei die potenziell
noch mehr Bock auf Linux haben,
als umgedreht. Aber Leute, die
sich hauptsächlich um Linux kümmern, die haben
überhaupt keinen Bock auf Windows.
Das kann ich persönlich an mir auch erkennen.
Also wenn einer sagt, Max, du musst dich jetzt
um Windows-Kisten kümmern, dann würde ich erstmal
alles in Bewegung setzen, um das zu verhindern.
Windows ist
der größte Pains-Champ, wenn
es um, also jetzt nicht
auf dem Desktop ist es auch der größte
Pains-Champ, ja, aber
Windows-Server ist wirklich das Schlimmste, was es gibt.
Okay, also du bist
alleine verantwortlich für Entwickler-
Linux und Windows. Dann geht's weiter.
Du machst dann nebenbei noch das ganze Active Directory.
Active Directory
in der Cloud. Exchange.
Mal gucken. Sind die das mit den...
Sind die das mit den Dübeln?
Fischer Dübel! Da hab ich doch recht gehabt.
Das sind die mit den Dübeln.
Das ist kein kleiner
Laden oder so.
So, und dann machst du noch nebenbei, nebenbei machst du noch Exchange, alleine, so, entscheidend wie es aussieht, alleine für dieses gesamte Ding.
Also ich meine, ich meine, allein schon, allein schon für nur für das hier, könntest du ohne Probleme jemand einstellen.
Nur dafür.
Und wenn das groß ist, auch nicht nur ein.
nur dafür kannst du schon eigentlich jemanden stellen gut der kann dann auch noch ein bisschen
active direkt entere all die mitmachen okay aber nur nur für nur für diesen punkt und nur
für das letzte ganz schön einstellen also das kommt ja noch dabei soll das war es aber noch
nicht das war es noch nicht geht noch weiter du wartest und optimiert die netzwerk infrastruktur
im Zusammenarbeit mit dieser Sophos-File.
Das heißt, du machst auch noch Netzwerk-Geschichten.
Und jetzt sicherlich
nicht einfach irgendwelches Ultra-Loop-Zeug,
wo du zweimal klicken musst, sondern was, wo du dich
auch mit auskennen musst.
Das allein ist auch schon wieder
ein eigener Job.
So, aber das war's
noch nicht. Es geht noch weiter.
Es geht noch
weiter. Du hast Spaß an der
Entwicklung und Pflege komplexer Python-Anwendungen,
insbesondere Web-Applications.
Du machst jetzt auch noch nebenbei
Kümmerst du dich noch um
Irgendwelche Anwendungen, ja
Also im Moment
Du kümmerst dich nicht nur um die Anwendung
Du entwickelst die Anwendung
Jaja, ich hab das auch auf Reddit gesehen
Und hab dann erstmal gegoogelt
Bevor ich das gepostet hab
Erstmal gegoogelt, ob das echt ist
Weil auf Reddit weißt du ja nie
Und das ist echt.
So, aber, Leute, das war es noch nicht.
Das war es immer noch nicht.
Also du bist jetzt schon irgendwie ein Windows-Linux-Admin-AD-Entra-ID-Exchange-Hybrid,
der nebenbei noch Netzwerk komplett macht.
Aber das reicht noch nicht.
Du bist auch noch Anwendungsentwickler.
So, aber das reicht immer noch nicht.
das ist nur für die High Performer mit dem richtigen
Grindset Mindset, gell, Leute
das ist nicht nur eine IT-Abteilung
das sind mehrere IT-Abteilungen zusammen
also ich glaube, das ist echt
eines der umfangreichsten
All-in-One-Dinger, die ich bisher gesehen habe
genau, die wollen einfach keine Low Performer
das ist nur für
die richtigen High Performer unter uns hier
genau, die
das auch machen für Mindestlohn
Weil ich kann mir vorstellen, wahrscheinlich sind nicht mehr die Bezahlungen gut.
Weil das steht hier nicht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Es steht nicht, was die zahlen.
Die zahlen bestimmt nicht viel.
Meistens ist das so in Kombination.
So wahnwitzige Vorstellungen, aber nichts bezahlen wollen.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Das war es immer noch nicht.
Du passt bestehende Anwendungen,
zum Beispiel Zeiterfassungssysteme,
Kiosksysteme an und erweiterst sie.
Also du machst nicht nur Python
Web-Anwendungen, du machst auch noch
irgendwelches, keine Ahnung,
Embedded-Zeug oder so.
Kiosksysteme.
Ja, so irgendwelche
Terminals oder so.
Mit einem Touchscreen dran und
wo halt irgendwas im Fullscreen läuft.
Sowas in der Richtung.
zeiterfassung system was war noch so das reicht aber immer noch nicht hier ging es ja nur um web
applikationen backends das reicht aber immer noch nicht das reicht nicht du wirst auch du musst auch
noch frontend entwickler werden du fliegst und gestaltet web oberflächen hat dem lcs javascript
also du bist linux linux windows admin du kümmerst dich um active direkt ente exchange dann bist du
noch Netzwerk-Admin, dann bist du
Python-Backend-Entwickler, dann bist du
vielleicht so ein halber Embedded
oder
naja,
vielleicht so ein bisschen
ähm
was weiß ich, Java-Entwickler
oder so, wer weiß, in was was programmiert ist,
diese Zeiterfassungssysteme, Kiosksysteme.
Vielleicht ist das irgendwelches
Microcontroller-Zeug, wobei
damit meistens eigentlich gemeint ist,
dass so eine Anwendung im Fullscreen
laufen, ja, und dann
musst du auch noch
Web-Entwickler, Frontend-Entwickler sein.
Du musst dich
auch noch mit der Fliege und der
Gestaltung von Web-Interfaces
und Web-Oberflächen auskennen.
So.
Dann
wird es nochmal ekliger.
Elektronenbasierte Kiosksysteme
aus, also Fullscreen-Browser im Endeffekt.
Das reicht noch nicht. Das reicht noch nicht.
Moment mal, das ist immer noch nicht.
Immer noch nicht vorbei.
Ja, das ist aber noch nicht vorbei.
Elektron-basierte
Kiosksysteme aus.
Das ja irgendwie eigentlich hierzu gehört.
Also wir wissen jetzt auch, was Kiosksysteme
sind. Die haben irgendeinen Browser im Fullscreen.
Elektron ist ja im Endeffekt ein Chromium
im Fullscreen dann in dem Fall.
Mit Node.js
dabei. Elektron-basierte
Kiosksysteme aus. So, aber
Leute, das ist noch nicht
genug. Das reicht immer noch nicht.
Das ist ein bisschen so wie früher.
Die Typen
auf irgendeinem Jahrmarkt gestanden haben und haben
so Wurstbeutel zusammengepackt.
Kennt ihr das?
Die dann da rumgestanden haben. Und selbst
wenn ich heute pleite gehe, hier gibt's
jetzt noch die Salami dabei und
das hier und wer nimmt's? So ungefähr fühlt sich
die Stellenanzeige an. Es reicht immer noch nicht.
Kommt immer noch was dabei.
So.
Aber wie gesagt, es reicht noch nicht.
Jetzt geht's noch weiter. Du übernimmst
das Skripting und die Automatisierung
wiederkehrende Aufgaben. Das ist das
Einzige, was ich mir irgendwie noch
zusätzlich gefallen lasse zu dem ersten ja du kümmerst dich hier um die um die
server und übernimmt scripting automatisierung wiederkehrende aufgaben
zum beispiel ab monitorin die platt das ist halt auch sehr sehr vage ja das ist
alles so in einem backups monitoring die platt das kann ja letztendlich die platt
alles irgendwie musst du automatisieren
So, aber das war es immer noch nicht.
Du musst natürlich auch noch technische Dokumentation erstellen, wobei das noch irgendwie dabei ist.
Und du unterstützt im Second Level Support. Support musst du auch noch machen.
Also wenn du noch Zeit hast, was ja easy ist, kein Problem.
Ich meine, wenn du das alles erledigt hast, machst du so die ersten zwei Stunden von Nacht, dann ist das alles erledigt.
Dann kannst du dich natürlich auch noch um den Support kümmern.
Also das ist glaube ich echt
Eines der abgedrehtesten
Stellenanzeigen
So von wir wollen alles in einem haben
Das haben wir ja schon öfters gehabt
Wir wollen alles in einem haben
Aber so ausgeprägt
Das habe ich sehr selten gesehen bisher
Schade dass nicht dabei steht was die bezahlen
Also ich könnte mich da drauf nicht bewerben.
Lass mal gucken, was ich davon machen könnte im Zweifelsfall.
Und ich meine, ich glaube mein Stream beweist, dass ich relativ breit mich auskenne.
Was Linux angeht und auch ganz brauchbar was so Anwendungsentwicklung angeht und Cloud-Infrastruktur und solche Geschichten.
Haben wir schon genug gemacht im Stream. Muss ich ja nicht beweisen. Also sieht man ja, ein bisschen breit Ahnung habe ich ja schon. Aber mal gucken, was ich jetzt davon machen könnte. Also, das Alleinverantwortliche finde ich übrigens auch krass.
Ja, Max, ich habe eine Stelle gefunden, Snow, schick mal, schick mal her, können wir uns auch gleich angucken.
Du bist allein verantwortlich, finde ich schon mal geil, aber okay, gucken wir mal, was ich machen könnte.
Administration, Weiterentwicklung, Pflege, Serverinfrastruktur, könnte ich machen, solange es nicht Windows ist.
Also ich könnte nur einen Teil vom ersten erfüllen.
Active Directory, Entra, ID, Exchange, könnte ich nicht machen.
Kein Plassen Schimmer von, würde ich auch nicht machen wollen, weil das ist im Endeffekt keck Windows
und Ökosystem drumherum.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass Junior Anwendungsentwickler...
Ja, habe ich.
Das ist wieder die Geschichte mit,
sie wollen irgendwelche Leute, die Ahnung haben,
aber keine Leute dahinführen, irgendwann mal Ahnung zu haben.
Das ist genauso wie, wir wollen nicht ausbilden,
aber wir wollen Leute haben, die ausgebildet sind.
Also das zweite könnte ich schon mal nicht machen.
Du wartest und optimierst die Netzwerkinfrastruktur in Zusammenarbeit mit Dienstleistern.
Okay, ich bin zwar kein krasser Netzwerkchecker, aber ich behaupte mal, mit ein bisschen Einarbeitung würde ich das eventuell hinkriegen, je nachdem wie viel Netzwerk die von mir wollen.
Ja, Netzwerk ist ein komplett eigenes Themengebiet, also wenn es da wirklich in die Tiefe geht, könnte ich das nicht machen.
Wenn es da letztendlich nur darum geht, irgendwelche Firewall-Regeln zusammen zu klicken, das könnte ich machen.
Du hast Spaß an der Entwicklung und Pflege komplexer Python Anwendungen, insbesondere
Web-Applications mit Flask.
Das würde ich wahrscheinlich hinkriegen.
Mit ein bisschen Übung und Einarbeitung.
Das würde ich wahrscheinlich über kurz oder lang hinkriegen.
Moment, warte mal, ich mach mir das mal auf.
Eigentlich wollte ich kein Schmick gucken und Stellenanzeigen, Schriemen jetzt machen,
aber das machen wir noch.
Also das würde ich wahrscheinlich mit ein bisschen Zeit und Einarbeitung, würde ich
das wahrscheinlich halbwegs hinkriegen.
Du passt bestehende
Anwendungen, Zeiterfassung, Kiosksysteme an,
erweiterst sie. Das würde ich wahrscheinlich
auch mit genug
Vorlaufzeit irgendwie noch halbwegs
auf die Reihe kriegen. Kommt darauf an, was da Sache
ist.
Du pflegst und gestaltest Web-Oberflächen.
Naja,
also ich krieg Web-Oberflächen und so schon hin,
aber wirklich gut kann ich das nicht.
Ihr wisst, wie wir uns hier immer abmühen mit CSS
und
Und HTML.
Ja, JavaScript macht mir ja mittlerweile sogar Spaß.
Also so semi-mäßig würde ich das hinkriegen.
Du verwaltest, rollt Elektron-basierte Kiosksysteme aus.
Ich habe schon mal was mit Elektron gemacht.
Das ist so ein Ding, wo ich denke, so über kurz oder lang, wenn ich mich damit intensiv beschäftige, würde ich, keine Ahnung, zur Hälfte hinkriegen.
Du übernimmst das Skripting und Automatisierung wiederkehrende Aufgaben.
Das ist das einzige, wo ich noch zusätzlich zu den Lieblingskisten sagen würde, ja, das kriege ich sicher hin.
Wobei es halt auch wieder darauf ankommt, was die wollen.
Wenn das irgendwelches Power-Shell-Gedöns ist, würde ich es zwar hinkriegen, hätte aber keinen Bock drauf.
Ja.
So, Support würde ich nicht machen.
Wollen.
Second-Level-Support fand ich ganz so schlimm wie First-Level, aber...
Kriegst nicht alles direkt ab, aber trotzdem hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Dokumentationen, naja, muss man halt manchmal machen.
Wobei ich mich da auf meiner Arbeit auch nicht unbedingt immer mit Ruhm bekleckere.
Ich mache immer oft die Sachen einfach und denke mir dann so, ja, okay, easy.
Nächstes Mal guckst du einfach in die History, das musst du nicht aufschreiben.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Bash History ist die einzig wahre beste Dokumentation, die es gibt.
Wer braucht Dokumentation, wenn er Bash History hat?
Overrated, outdated, she baited.
Ja, ZSH-History geht auch.
Aber Shell-History.
Shell-History ist die beste Dokumentation.
Ich finde es immer toll,
wenn ich Dokumentation finde,
zu was,
was ich jetzt brauche.
Also meistens zu faul,
ausführlich selbst was zu schreiben.
So, was haben wir denn sonst?
der chat ich gucke gleich auf die anderen sachen im chat gerade mal das hier fertig gucken okay
was haben wir sonst noch dein anwendungs besitzt eine eigenständige strukturierte arbeitsweise
sowie teamfähigkeit war okay standardspruch du bist bewandt in peisen bringt idealerweise
erfangen flasch sql als system würde ich schon rausfallen flasch habe ich glaube ich einmal
irgendwie beispiel anwendung gemacht mit paar zeilen das war es sql alchemie verwendet bin
ja auch kein großer preis an hacker man du beherrschst den umgang mit linux
server ja das mache ich das ist das einzige von der ganzen sache wo ich sage
ja hundertprozentig das passt und windows server niederhört bei mir schon
auf du hast gute kenntnisse in html css und javascript ich würde mal sagen ganz
brauchbar ja entere id ad exchange on premise oder absolut kein plan davon
kein plan davon kann ich nichts da könnte ich nichts machen und will ich auch nicht machen
du hast erfahrung im bereich netzwerk und firewall so force von vorteil habe ich
noch nie was damit zu tun gehabt und ein grundverständnis von für elektronen deshalb
okay das habe ich ja du hast mehrere jahre berufserfahrung diesem bereich in diesem vor
Vor allem, Leute, in diesem Bereich, in welchem von den acht eigentlich?
Die tun ja gerade so, als ist das ja so weltweit etablierter Standard, dieser Bereich.
Okay, deine stellenspezifischen Vorteile.
mal gucken was es hier für gratis gibt für diesen für diesen job okay eine
abwechslungsreiche arbeitsalltag das kann ich mir vorstellen das kann ich mir
vorstellen du bist ja auch fünf it abteilung in einem 48 jahre
Subscription. Nice.
Pog.
Abwechslungsreiche Arbeit.
Sicherer Arbeitsplatz. Ja, dass die dich nicht mehr
loswerden wollen, kann ich verstehen.
Mit moderne...
Mit moderne Produktion. Was?
Mit moderne Produktion?
Mit moderner
Produktion? Aber verstehe ich nicht, wie das
was bedeuten soll. Und einer professionellen
Arbeitsausstattung. Oh, das ist aber nett,
dass sie mir den Arbeitsplatz stellen.
Das ist aber nett von denen, oder?
Dass ich nicht mein eigenes Nordbock mitbringen muss.
Sowie eine angenehme Arbeitskultur in einem motivierten und global ausgerichteten,
okay, Standard, bla bla bla, langfristig Karriereperspektive mit geförderten Personen, bla bla bla,
und ein unbefristeter Anstieg in einem Inhabergefühl, bla bla bla.
Vorteile.
Sind Firmen-Events wirklich Vorteile?
Ich guck grad mal, was die sonst noch so haben.
Also das ist wirklich komplett utopisch.
Wisst ihr, was ich mir vorstellen könnte?
Dass das eine Stelle ist, die eigentlich schon besetzt ist.
Und sie müssen es irgendwie ausschreiben oder so.
Und...
Also vielleicht ist das jetzt zu kekalu, was ich mir denke.
Die wollen eigentlich gar keiner, der sich da drauf bewirbt.
Meint ihr, das könnte sein?
Oder ist das zu keck-alo-move, was ich mir da gerade denke?
Ja, Chat-Mine auch könnte sein.
Weil anders, da kann ich mir das echt nicht erklären.
Ich meine, so unfähig können die Stellenanzeigen-Ersteller doch gar nicht sein.
Oder sowas da rauszuhauen, ernsthaft zu meinen.
Jawohl, das ist es, da bewerbe ich mich jetzt drauf.
Doch, die haben Verbindung zu Dübel Fischer, weil...
Fischer Holding.
Dazu gehört auch Fischer Dübel dabei.
Ja, Moment.
Du gehörst dann zu Fischer Automation, aber du kümmerst dich natürlich selbstverständlich um Exchange
für die komplette Fischer Holding, TEG Deutschland, Slowakei und Fischer Automation.
Die Person, die das geschrieben hat, wusste, was sie macht.
Oder aber irgendein Personaler hat das geschrieben und hat halt von denjenigen, die was suchen, so eine Liste bekommen.
Und hat das halt mehr oder weniger zu einer Stellenanzeige zusammen geschustert.
Ach, sonst suchen sie nix, okay.
Sie lieben es zu tüfteln, Technik begeistert sie.
Das muss ich ja mal bookmarken.
Das ist geil, das Ding.
Okay, jetzt wollte ich hier nochmal gucken.
Hier hat doch irgendjemand einen Freund.
Sekunde.
Und dann müssen wir uns noch die Schnellanzeige von Snow angucken.
Irgendjemand hat was mit BSD vorhin hier geschrieben.
Ah ja, Marius, kannst du kurz erläutern, wie aus deiner Perspektive BSD gegen Dienungsverhältnis?
Ich steige heute in BSD an und wollte mal hören, wie das Verhältnis zwischen Dienungs- und Unix- und BSD ist.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe BSD nur mal ganz vereinzelt installiert in der VM und ein bisschen mit rumgebastelt.
Ich hatte mal eine Weile OpenSense, was auf BSD basiert.
Ich hatte mal eine Weile FreeNAS, was damals auch auf BSD basierte.
Also ich habe eher den Eindruck, dass die Sachen, die auf BSD aufgesetzt haben in den letzten Jahren, eher Richtung Linux gegangen sind.
Wobei ich das auch mit meiner Vorsicht genießen würde, was ich jetzt sage, weil mir fällt nur ein Beispiel ein und das ist TrueNAS.
Die sind von, also FreeNAS, was jetzt TrueNAS irgendwie ist, die sind von BSD auf Linux dabei umzusteigen.
Ansonsten keine Ahnung von BSD.
Kann ich gar nichts dazu sagen.
alles andere ist jetzt irgendwie ausdenken
ist das deine mann nach zu viele themen die sie da verlangen du meinst hier bei
dem ball fischer automation ja natürlich das ist alles in vier it abteilungen in einer stelle
BSD sauberer ist, kann ich nicht sagen
Ich weiß nur, dass du bei BSD
wohl zum größten Teil so eine zentrale
Config-Datei hast für alles
Aber wie gesagt, keine Ahnung
So, jetzt gucken wir uns nochmal von Snow die Stellenanzeige an
Wo er meint, er hat irgendwas gefunden
wo die für Mindestlohn
Das gucken wir uns jetzt noch schnell an
Support E-Commerce
Support E-Commerce Software Trainee
Achso, ja gut, dann denken die natürlich die Billen nicht aus und können den Mindestlohn bezahlen.
Ein Moment, Mindestgehalt, also okay, Mindestgehalt gleich, eigentlich haben wir nicht Bock mehr zu bezahlen, oder wie?
Plus Gewinnbeteiligung
Überbezahlung nach Erfahrung und Leistung
Als Trainee
In Österreich
Was suchen sie denn?
Warum ist der am Billiard spielen im Hintergrund?
Wir suchen eine motivierte Verstellung für unseren Support.
Okay, da wäre es bei mir...
Chat!
Da wäre es bei mir schon vorbei.
Support ist Pains Champ hoch 10.
Keiner will Support machen.
Werde Profi unserer E-Commerce-Software.
Optimal bringst du Erfahrung mit Online-Shop-Systemen,
Web-Servern, Hosting, Datenbanken und Basic-Scripting-Calling-Skills mit.
Und wir bilden dich auf unsere Software komplett von...
Okay, das sind halt Support-Mitarbeiter.
Support wird dir immer schlecht bezahlt.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, 28k ist halt schon nix.
Das ist jetzt wirklich gar nichts.
Das ist wahrscheinlich...
Ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Mindestlohn in Österreich aussieht.
Ah ja.
Sehr gute PC-Kenntnisse.
Das ist nicht die IP.
Die habe ich copy-pasted hier gerade.
Der Browser hat die auch so completed.
Na gut.
An sich ist es halt ein Support-Job, wobei man ehrlich sagen muss,
Pizza-Sessions.
Okay, wenn du dann irgendwann um 23 Uhr
noch rumgabbelst oder was.
Stressresistenz, ja gut, das ist Support, ja.
Aber ganz ehrlich, 28k,
das ist ja nix.
Also für 28k,
weiß ich nicht, das...
sich da irgendwie einen Stress geben, da kann ich
ja verstehen, dass die Leute lieber harzen.
Nee, also...
Sie schreiben zwar, du kannst theoretisch noch mehr verdienen,
aber naja, da bin ich immer
skeptisch, ob das dann auch wirklich so
eintritt.
Aber ich glaube,
das OpenZFS von Linux
hat mittlerweile
mehr Features als das NativeBSD
ZFS oder benutzt
BSD mittlerweile auch OpenZFS.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Chat, wenn ich was übersehen habe, sag Bescheid.
Scroll nochmal kurz hoch.
bugelkuch sagt er benutzt jetzt doch das ist nice er hat der stream sicher schon gelohnt
der command geht nicht echt nicht warum nicht moment es ist ist der
night bot mal wieder abgekackt geht doch hier ausrufzeichen 1 guck da
sind wir nicht das macht geht das
aber das müsste bei euch auch funktionieren
sondern gucken wir doch mal was auf github so trendet nach dem reply ja das kann sein
oder froh bist geh weg was was trendet denn oft gehabt diese woche zeichnen trending this week
da also zeige ich mal her
ja most intuitive desktop api klein ist das so was wie postman
oder was ist das?
Kenn ich nicht. Kennt ihr das?
API-Client
for Modern Developers.
Ja, das ist sowas ähnliches wie Postman,
würde ich sagen.
Crack ist am Start.
Bei Crack muss ich immer
an den Garlic Farmer denken.
Guckt jemand auch Epic NPC Man?
Bruno ist besser als Postman.
Das kenne ich gar nicht.
Ich kenne Insomnia, was früher Postwoman hieß, als Software.
Aber das ist sowas wie Postman im Endeffekt, oder?
Ah, Pricings kosten was.
Hobby.
Nice.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir.
Das ist vom Gründer von Insomnia.
Aha, gut, dann ist das sowas wie Postman.
Okay, Moment.
Das da, meint ihr?
Ah, das ist auch sowas wie Postman.
ja das sieht auch sehr post beim mäßig aus
reinventing api kleid was sie haben den hund als logo stimmt ja
ich wollte ich wollte ich bei den github trends jetzt irgendwie wieder
rauskommen in sommer ist auch müll okay ich muss mich aber auch an der stelle
also nicht hier sondern ich benutze kein post man kann in sommer und sonst was
ich benutze 90 prozent einfach gehören
ich weiß dass es irgendwie oldschool und mit den anderen kannst du viel dollere
sachen machen und und überhaupt und auch viel besser die response die angucken
aber zu 90 prozent ist curl einfach ausreichend für mich
curl beste
sowas was trendet denn sonst noch
Audiobooks from E-Books.
Aha.
Kann man sich das vorlesen lassen quasi.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Ich habe mich schon öfters mal gewünscht, anstatt irgendwas lesen zu können, es einfach nebenbei zu hören.
Das ist eigentlich cool.
Das hat was.
Das muss ich mir mal bookmarken
Achso ich habe kein Audio hier in der VM
Okay
Open Notebook
Eine der 30.000 Notiz Apps
AI
Okay, ne
MinIO
Gab's da nicht letztens irgendwie Stress?
Gab's da nicht irgendwie Stress?
Ich hab da im Hinterkopf
Irgendwas war doch da die letzten 1-2 Wochen
Da gab's doch Stress
Die haben keine
Genau, die bieten keine Container-Images mehr an
Das war's, ja, richtig
da haben es die Leute aufgeregt
in den Issues
und war das auch nicht so, dass die ihre
dass die in ihrem Webinterface
irgendwie mal ein Feature, irgendwie eine Konsole
im Webinterface entfernt haben
wo sich auch alle aufgeregt haben
kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern
jetzt wo ich euch da hab ihr seid doch hier messer messer fire q und hacker
mens hat jemand von euch schon mal einen bitcoin not containerisiert
also ich habe nur fertige images gefunden die admin rechte also die hut rechte brauchen ich
würde gern einen container bauen das ohne hutrechte ein bitcoin container
bauen dass der ohne hutrechte läuft hat das jemand schon mal gemacht von euch
wahrscheinlich aber das probiere ich auf der arbeit gerade ein bitcoin container
zu bauen
der ohne gut recht läuft so für die gut brauche ich weiß es auch nicht genau aber die ganzen
containers also ein container ist ganz wird der möchte sogar den docker socket in den container
weitergeleitet haben um das sie dann docker in docker machen können wofür auch immer das
ein Bitcoin-Node brauchst.
Machst du immer noch Blockchain auf der Arbeit? Ja.
Und jetzt kommt auch noch
demnächst Bitcoin dabei.
Bisher ist es nur Polygon
und Ethereum.
Aber bald ist es auch
noch Bitcoin.
Hast du Bitcoin? Ne.
Hi Max, hast du mal Jobangebote...
Warte mal.
Kurz was trinken.
Okay.
Hi Max, hast du mal Jobangebote aus der Schweiz bekommen?
Oder hast du mal drüber nachgedacht?
Also ich habe keine Jobangebote aus der Schweiz bekommen.
ich habe generell eigentlich noch nie groß jobangebote in dem sind bekommen
weil ich halt ewig gesucht habe also ich habe mich habe ich auf youtube
schon immer schon immer mal ab und zu leute angeschrieben hier willst du nicht
und hast du aber da habe ich mich die ernsthaft darum gekümmert ich meine ich
habe die letzten zehn jahre quasi einmal der arbeitgeber gewechselt ist nicht so
euch da irgendwie groß am gucken wer wenn ich mir jobangebote angucken dann
eher eigentlich jetzt fast vorfahren ja und den aktuellen job den habe ich ja
auch nicht so richtig durch irgendein jobangebot stellenanzeige oder so
gefunden das war glückliche fügung und zwar ich
habe doch ein video auf youtube gemacht wo ich gesagt habe ich habe keinen bock
mal ich suche neuen job und ehemaliger kollege von mir den ich noch von früher
kannte, hat mich dann angeschrieben,
Max, willst du nicht zu uns?
Bei uns ist schon irgendwie so ein halbes Jahr eine Stelle offen
und die finden keinen, der passt. Willst du nicht
zu uns?
Ja, warum nicht? Zeig mal her.
Und jetzt bin ich da.
Das hat richtig
gut gepasst auch.
Also jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich
da groß geguckt, aber ich lese mal kurz die
Frage weiter.
Kann ich,
sage ich gleich was zu.
TSFox, danke schön für den Sub.
Also ich habe aber tatsächlich auch schon mal drüber nachgedacht, in die Schweiz.
Aber jetzt nicht irgendwie so aktiv geguckt, einfach nur mal so den Gedanke ein bisschen durchgekaut im Kopf.
Ich wäre der Sache nicht abgeneigt, prinzipiell in die Schweiz zu gehen.
Ein Kollege von mir, der ist in die Schweiz ausgewandert.
Ich bin seit einem Dreivierteljahr hier, war auf jeden Fall beste Entscheidung.
Vor einem Jahr haben wir noch über schlechte Arbeits- und Arbeitgeber gesprochen.
Es ist schön, dass das geklappt hat bei dir und auch, dass du da happy bist.
Hast du nicht Bedenken?
Also, das muss ich jetzt mal fragen.
Wie ist das da mit Probezeit?
Ich meine...
Es ist ja ein bisschen so, wenn man einen Arbeitgeber wechselt und ein halbes Jahr Probezeit hat,
es ist eh immer schon so ein bisschen wackelig, weil man ja manchmal vielleicht von einem Job wechselt,
wo man jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig Bock drauf hat, aber immerhin weiß, was man hat.
Wechselt man, weil man sich denkt, okay, bei dem anderen ist es besser.
So, da ist so ein halbes Jahr Probezeit ja schon immer ein bisschen blöd, weil du sagst,
Ah, wenn die jetzt irgendwie führungstechnisch da neue Entscheidungen treffen, so nach dem Motto, wir machen jetzt hier komplett Stopp mit Neueinstellungen, schmeißen alles raus, was das letzte halbe Jahr angefangen hat, kannst du ja nichts dagegen machen. Also ein bisschen wackelig ist das ja mit Probezeit immer.
Aber wie ist das, wenn du in der Schweiz anfängst?
Weil da hängt ja noch deutlich mehr dran.
Ja, wenn mich hier in Deutschland jemand in Frankfurt rausschmeißt, findest du eigentlich fast um die Ecke.
Wenn Frankfurt ist, wo du hinspuckst, irgendein Rechenzentrum, IT-Dienstleister oder Finanzbranche, irgendwelche Unternehmen.
Da findest du an jeder Ecke was.
Und es ist da, wo du wohnst, wo ich hier das Haus habe und wo ich mich auskenne.
In der Schweiz hängt ja dann deutlich mehr dran.
Also wenn du in die Schweiz ziehst und die sagen nach zwei, drei Monaten,
ah, keine Ahnung, hier, Vorstand hat neue Dinger beschlossen,
wir wollen jetzt doch keine neuen Leute mehr und schmeißen alles raus, die in der Probezeit sind,
was machst du dann?
Hast du da keine Bedenken deswegen gehabt?
Tatsächlich ist die Probezeit in der Schweiz drei Monate, aber in der Schweiz kann es jederzeit rausgeschmissen werden ohne Grund keine Abfindung.
Okay.
Ja, ich finde es in Deutschland teilweise auch sogar schon ein bisschen übertrieben mit Kündigungsschutz, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich war ja ganz ungläubig hier, wo ich mal gesagt habe im Stream, ich arbeite nicht bei einer Bank, ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung.
Aber ich darf selbstverständlich ETFs und sowas kaufen, das ist kein Problem.
Was ich nicht machen darf, und da muss ich auch regelmäßig Schulungen zu besuchen, was ich nicht machen darf, ist, wenn ich jetzt auf der Arbeit irgendwas höre, was noch nicht allgemein bekannt ist, dass ich dann sage, ah, ich hab gehört, die und die bringen jetzt demnächst ein neues Produkt raus, ich kauf mal ein paar Aktien von denen vorher.
Oder so, das darf ich nicht.
Aber ansonsten ETFs kaufen und so, klar, kein Problem. Darf ich.
muss ja keiner wissen ja nun trotzdem nicht erlaubt
ja genau so und jetzt muss ich sagen doch mal zu der sache mit was dann hier
ich musste also wegen der wegen der sache kündigungsschutz da war ich ja
tatsächlich überrascht, wie krass das in Deutschland
ist, ja, das fand ich fast schon
zu heftig, also ich hab ja
mal hier im Stream letztens gefragt, ja, wie
ist das denn eigentlich, mal angenommen,
ja, ich hätte jetzt eine Firma, wobei ich hab ja
eine Firma, aber ich bin da der Einzige, der
da arbeitet und wirklich arbeiten tu ich da
auch aktuell nicht, also mal
angenommen, ich würd jetzt hier voll krass durchstarten
mit Content
äh, Production
überall und mach hier ganz, ganz
viel Zeug, so, das wird dann
voll groß und ich verdien damit richtig viel
Kohle und ich stelle irgendwie
keine Ahnung, 40 Leute ein oder so
und hab dann hier, mach dann
deutschen Linus
Tech-Tipps oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
So, habt jetzt total viele Leute am Start,
so, dann stelle ich irgendjemand ein
und ich stelle nach, keine Ahnung,
ich stelle nach einem Jahr
fest oder so, der Typ
geht mir mega auf den Sack
und, ähm,
der hat immer was zu meckern an dem, was ich sage
und der chillt
den halben Tag rum
Ich habe ja fast gar keine Möglichkeit, den loszuwerden als Arbeitgeber in Deutschland.
Also das ist ja richtig krass.
Ich habe gedacht, was nicht stimmt, hat mir der Chat erzählt.
Ich habe gedacht eigentlich, dass ich ordnungsgemäß immer kündigen kann.
Also ordentlich kündigen kann oder wie man das genau nennt.
Also sprich unter Einhaltung von Kündigungsfristen und sonst was.
Da hat mich der Chat aber eines Besseren belehrt.
Und wir wissen ja, der Twitch-Chat, der weiß immer Bescheid.
Das ist gar nicht so.
Also ich kann selbst,
ich kann selbst, wenn ich,
hat mir der Chat erzählt, ja.
Ich kann selbst,
wenn ich sage, ich will den Typ nicht mehr bei mir haben,
weil ich halt einfach nicht mit dem klarkomme
und ich finde, er passt nicht in den Laden rein.
Ja, zieht vielleicht auch noch die anderen Leute mit runter,
mit seinem Gemecker und was auch immer.
Also irgendwelche Gründe sage ich, okay, will ich nicht.
Da werde ich den Kerl nicht los.
Ich kann doch nicht mal sagen, ich kündige dem ganz fristgerecht ordentlich.
Das ist wohl riesige Hürden verbunden.
Das fand ich halt auch schon zu krass.
Also muss doch auch irgendjemand loswerden können, wenn es nicht passt.
Ich meine, wir müssen es nicht machen wie bei den Amis.
Ja, hallo, tschüss, morgen bist du weg.
Aber irgendwie die Chance haben, jemand loszuwerden, musst du doch.
Kannst du dein Einstiegsgehalt nach der Ausbildung nennen?
Ja, 33.500 Euro im Jahr war das damals.
Wenn du das heute hochrechnest, sind das irgendwie, glaube ich, 44k oder sowas.
Oder 42k oder irgendwie so in dem Dreh, wenn du das so inflationsmäßig hochrechnest.
Belfi 6 ist bei mir im Steam Account.
Aber ich kann es gerade noch nicht spielen.
So.
Was sagen die alten Kollegen?
du meinst dort wo ich vorher gearbeitet habe mit denen gehe ich noch ab und zu
am mittagessen ein paar habe ich immer noch in kontakt
ich habe ja das stimmt ich habe freiwillig die fdp gewinnt richtig ja
und ist doch ist doch sogar von dem was ich jetzt gesagt habe ziemlich das
passend oder
ach so du hast okay dann
wie geht es dem kaboom das weiß ich nicht
Ja, meine generelle Frage bzw. Internetbrowser, welchen würdest du empfehlen?
Gibt es einen Grund, warum du Chromium benutzt?
Ich würde Firefox empfehlen.
Mag jetzt widersprüchlich sein, aber Firefox ist aktuell wahrscheinlich der beste Browser.
Also gerade wenn man auf sowas wie Adblocks, was richtig funktioniert und so Wert legt.
Ich habe hier zwar U-Block Origin Lite, aber U-Block Origin Firefox hat immer noch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Ne, mit YouTube-Leuten habe ich eigentlich nichts mehr zu tun.
Warum ich Secure Boot nicht aktiv habe?
Weil ich Veracrypt Vollverschlüsselung habe von meinem System und das geht angeblich zusammen.
Habe ich aber noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich muss aber eh Windows neu installieren.
Und ich habe hier schon eine 4TB NVMe SSD liegen.
Hier, da ist die Packung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es hört.
Die baue ich mir ein und installiere Windows neu.
25H2.
Mach Secure Boot an.
Und dann geht das.
Es liegt aber nicht nur daran, dass ich kein Battlefield 6 spiele.
Ich bin geistig auch gerade nicht so frei, wie ich gerne wäre,
mich mit Sachen zu beschäftigen.
Ne, DNS-Adblocker habe ich schon lange abgeschaltet.
Das einzige, wofür ein DNS-Adblocker noch halbwegs brauchbar ist, ist für Mobile-Geräte, wo es ein bisschen Werbung blockt, aber auch nicht mehr so viel.
slim train schreibt er ist seit ende januar auch mit der umschule zum fisi durchsuche dann was bei
einer firma die selber soll netzwerk macht thomas krenn die kenne ich nur von ihrem wiki was es
früher gab früher gab es das thomas krenn wiki da standen ganz praktische sachen früher drin
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Habe ich nicht.
So.
Eigentlich wollte ich noch
GitHub-Trends fertig gucken.
Hauptsache,
AI.
Was ist denn die
Hugging-Chat-App?
Ai Ai Multiplayer in Rust nicht für Rust in Rust
Ai Ai Ach das trendet auch mal wieder ok
Crap Alternative
Wobei, da habe ich ja schon öfters gesagt
So Sachen kommen bei mir nicht in die Tüte
Ich sage nicht, dass diese ganzen
Standard Tools
Rewritten in Rust, dass man das nicht machen sollte
Oder dass das schlecht ist oder so
Die haben sicherlich ihre Vorteile
Ich habe ja auch mal eine Weile Exa benutzt
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das noch drauf haben, ne haben wir nicht
Als LS Alternative
Das Ding ist nur
Warum ich das nicht mache, das heißt nicht, dass ihr das auch machen sollt
Ich bin so oft
auf Linux-Servern unterwegs, wo eben die Standard-Tools
drauf sind. Und
wenn ich bei mir alles super krass
customised habe, also ich benutze kein
LS mehr, ich benutze kein Grepp mehr, ich habe
Wim nur mit 30 Milliarden Plugins,
dann gewöhnt man sich da dran und
verlernt mit der Zeit, wie man die
Standard-Tools ordentlich benutzt.
Und das will ich nicht. Ich will
immer noch aus dem FF wissen, wie
ich ein Find ordentlich absetze
oder wie ich ordentlich was greppe
oder wie ich relativ
Raw Wim ordentlich benutze.
Deswegen benutze ich diese ganzen Alternativen nicht.
Ich bin übrigens auch mal gespannt, wie das bei Ubuntu läuft.
Was soll ich nicht Ubuntu, Jubantu.
Wie das bei Jubantu so läuft.
Die ersetzen ja gerade ihre ganzen Standard-Tools durch Rust-Alternativen.
Und haben damit regelmäßig Probleme, weil die halt doch noch nicht so 100%ig kompatibel sind zu den alten...
Standard Core Tools
Varianten.
Gibt es regelmäßig Probleme.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe auch nicht,
warum.
LS ist vollkommen fein.
FIND ist vollkommen fein.
CREP ist vollkommen fein.
Seed AWK ist vollkommen fein.
Also ich verstehe nicht, warum es ein Rewrite
dieser Tools braucht, ehrlich gesagt.
Das leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Und für mich ist das aktuell eher ein Grund,
belehrt mich eines Besseren.
Vielleicht liege ich da ja auch falsch.
Für mich ist das aktuell
ein Grund, Ubuntu nicht zu benutzen.
Auf dem Server.
Okay.
Ich benutze Ubuntu jetzt eh schon nicht mehr auf dem Server.
Die haben mich verloren,
als die einmal angefangen haben
mit ihrem ganzen Snap-Gedöns.
Aber viel nerviger fand ich Netzwerkkonfiguration
in YAML. Das hat mich so abgefuckt,
dass ich keinen Bock mehr hatte.
Und seitdem eigentlich nur noch Debian verwende.
Ich bin bei Debian schon.
Netzwerk-Config in YAML.
Ja.
Die haben Ubuntu-Netplan.
Nennt sich das.
Guck.
Sowas musst du da machen.
Wenn du Netzwerk-Karten konfigurieren willst in Ubuntu, sieht es so aus.
Ich finde das eklig.
Vielleicht ist es, wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat,
wie so viel ist nicht eklig.
Aber mir hat das nicht gefallen.
Für mich war es ein Grund zu sagen,
Alter, Ubuntu, kein Bock mehr.
Ich habe dann quasi gesagt,
Ubuntu,
piss dich, Alter.
Und dann
habe ich nur noch Debian verwendet.
Und auf der Arbeit stellt sich die Frage eh nicht,
weil auf der Arbeit ist
Red Hat am Start.
Weil Business Enterprise.
Okay, das...
Da muss ich was zu sagen.
Rewrite while memory safe. Okay.
Bei Sachen wie
Sudo, das ist wahrscheinlich auch so ziemlich
das einzige Kommando, was mir jetzt so einfällt,
spontan, da verstehe ich den
Rewrite.
Weil da gab es ja schon in der Vergangenheit öfters
Probleme und Sudo hat ja logischerweise,
wenn es Probleme gibt,
auch sicherheitsrechtliche
Bedenken
gibt es dann.
Mit Sudo kannst du gut werden.
Das verstehe ich, aber
ganz ehrlich, ob ein LS,
ein CAT, ein
Grab oder ein Fiend
jetzt 100%
Memory safe ist und du das nicht
zum Crashen bringen kannst,
es ist scheißegal.
Das juckt null.
Aber was...
Crasht halt LS, ja?
Oder kannst mit einem LS vielleicht
im schlimmsten Fall
keine Ahnung,
die Kiste, im aller, aller, aller schlimmsten Fall
irgendwie vielleicht einen Server zum Absturz bringen,
weil...
Wie willst du das machen?
Ja, also, da sehe ich den Vorteil davon einfach nicht.
Zumal man ja auch mal sagen muss, die alten Tools, die sind jetzt ja auch nicht ungetestet oder so.
Die sind ja relativ bugfrei.
Wenn du was Spezielles wissen willst, kannst du ruhig fragen.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich eher so wie in der Schule, wenn der Lehrer fragt, was habt ihr nicht verstanden?
Und dann einer sagt, ja, alles nochmal.
Aber schön, dass du da bist, Coach.
Pog.
Ja, für Sudo verstehe ich das ja.
Sudo ist so ein Ding, wo ich sage, okay, das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Aber ob LS jetzt wirklich rewritten in Rust werden muss, damit das Memory safer ist, das bezweifle ich einfach mal.
Ja, aber was soll es denn großartig machen?
LS läuft als dein User?
und also ich weiß ich stelle mir dieses angriffsszenario irgendwie nicht so
nicht so bedrohlich vor wenn du shell access hast auf dem system kannst du
kannst du eh alles mögliche machen was du willst wenn du commands ausführen kannst
Du bräuchtest nen Fall?
Keine Ahnung, mir fällt da gar nichts großartig ein.
Ah, okay.
Ich weiß nicht, was...
Was? Ach, LSPAP-Code der LS aufruft. Ah ja.
Ist dann halt so.
Der kann aber auch, wenn PHP-Code LS aufrufen kann, kannst du damit auch irgendwas...
Ach, du meinst, wenn du irgendwo einen Exek-Trainer hast im PHP, der LS aufruft und LS...
Ja.
Also, wenn du irgendwie
ungefilterten
String-Sachen irgendwie
in den Exek reinpipes hinter den LS,
ja, da kannst du, ich meine,
okay, dann kannst du aber auch
gleich ein Semikolon hinmachen
und irgendwas anderes reinschreiben.
Ja, ich
ich verstehe da schon,
dass es da theoretische Szenarien
gibt,
aber bei einem LS und
bei einem Cat oder bei einem Crab
oder sonst was.
Also da muss ich schon sehr
kreativ werden, dass mir da irgendwas einfällt,
wo das Probleme macht.
Nutzt du Ansible für private
Zwecke? Ne.
Ich installiere so selten mein Kram neu
und ich habe ja auch gar nicht mehr so viel da laufen.
Ich habe hier mal ein Unraid
laufen, was
seit, keine Ahnung, zwei Jahren
oder so einfach vor sich hin werkelt.
Mit ein paar Docker-Containern drauf
und und einer vm fertig reicht nächtlich wird er singt auf eine externe platte aus ist
so
aber jetzt die github trends alle fertig
deep ai trendet juckt mich nicht sie wheat fs was ist das sie wieder fs fast ist die
blüte start system weil supports cloud
ok ich habe anhand der beschreibung jetzt kein plan was es ist was ist sie wheat fs
Ist das sowas wie ZEVS oder sowas?
Oder wie?
Aha.
Zu 100%ig gecheckt
habe ich es aber immer noch nicht.
Wann ich das
verwenden würde.
Okay, whatever.
Auf jeden Fall mal ein spannendes Projekt.
Zwischen dem ganzen AI-Kram hier bei GitHub Trends.
Automation Tower Defense RTS.
Ich glaube, das kenne ich.
Ich glaube, das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ja.
DrawDB
Online Database
Diagram and SQL Generator
Okay, waren ja mal ein paar ganz interessante
Projekte diesmal dabei.
Nicht nur AI-Krempel.
Findest du AI ist eine Bubble?
Schwer zu sagen.
Also
was ich merke ist,
dass dieser ganze AI-Hype
Hype
Sich ein bisschen ins negative gedreht hat
Oder gerade am drehen ist also was ich damit meine ist zum beispiel war es eine ganze zeit lang
Im trend das überall geworben wurde mit features
Also jede software hat irgendwie dran geschrieben power bei mit
Features mit hier und da
Und da habe ich gerade so die letzten Wochen oder vielleicht die letzten 1-2 Monate, merkt man, wie sich der Wind da ein bisschen dreht, vor allem bei Technikinteressierten, dass man sagt, okay, ist es für mich wirklich eine Bereicherung, wenn es AI-powered ist oder geht es nicht eher darum, um die eigentlichen Features, die dieses AI-powered ermöglicht.
Also will ich jetzt, mal angenommen, ich suche ein Notizprogramm, bringt mir das was, wenn es AI-powered ist? Interessiert mich das? Bringt das was? Ist das nicht eher irgendwie übertriebenes Feature-Kram, was im Zweifelsfall mir nur auf den Sack geht? Oder hängt da irgendwas dran, was mir was bringt?
Ja, also man sollte nicht dann schreiben hier bla bla bla, powered by AI, sondern wenn man was verkaufen will, sollte man vielleicht schreiben, keine Ahnung, automatische E-Mail Zusammenfassung, powered by AI oder sowas.
Und ich habe die letzten Wochen eher gemerkt, dass der Wind sich so ein bisschen dreht, was das angeht, dass die Leute immer skeptischer werden, wenn da einfach nur drauf geklatscht ist, powered by AI.
Dunas, Dankeschön für den Sub, 27 Jahre, Prox Subscription.
Ja gut, Microsoft ist immer noch super krass am AI-Verkaufen.
Also ich kann euch da was erzählen von der Arbeit.
Also vom Hören auf der Arbeit.
Wir hatten letztens einen Termin mit unserem IT-Abteilungsleiter.
Und der hat erzählt, er war letztens bei Microsoft.
und sie wollten eigentlich
wegen was war er nochmal da?
Ich glaube,
ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher. Ich glaube,
es ging da drum,
wie das ist mit Daten
in der EU speichern
und sowas. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
um was es da wirklich genau ging.
Zumindest hat er gesagt,
dass Google,
also da war Google am Start,
Microsoft am Start, wahrscheinlich auch Amazon am Start und hat gesagt, Google hatte eine super Antwort auf ihre Fragen.
Microsoft hat quasi auf die Frage am Anfang, ist die irgendwie in zwei Sätzen eingegangen und hat danach nur noch über AI geredet.
Wobei das überhaupt nicht Thema war.
und hat gesagt microsoft versucht einfach auf teufel komm raus aktuell irgendwie überall drauf
zu hauen und den leuten anzudrehen kappa bill und das empfand er als sehr nervig dass microsoft
weil sie immer nur gesagt hat die ganze zeit ja okay aber ei so nach dem motto
ja könnt ihr uns garantieren wenn daten in der eu gespeichert wenn ja mit ei
machen wir alles hat gesagt das ging ihm echt auf den keks und du konntest im
prinzip eigentlich den termin mit microsoft komplett vergessen weil
prinzipiell nur über er all geredet wurde nicht über das eigentliche worüber
geredet werden sollte
Und so schätze ich das an vielen Stellen ein, dass den Leuten langsam ein bisschen auf den Sack geht.
So, Viertelstunde schon keine Package.
Leute, ich habe vor Viertelstunde Package-Updates gemacht.
Gib nächstes Package-Update.
So mag ich das.
Nee, wir müssen nicht rebooten.
Was glaubst du, welche IT-Jobs als erstes verschwinden oder weniger werden aufgrund von der...
IT-Jobs bin ich mir gar nicht mehr so sicher.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass viele Bullshit-Jobs verschwinden, die den ganzen Tag nur irgendwelche Sachen copy-pasten oder...
Oder wo man nicht genau weiß, diese Jobs, wo man nicht so genau weiß, was machen die eigentlich?
Die sehe ich viel eher verschwinden als erstes.
IT-Jobs?
Bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob da so viele verschwinden werden.
Ich meine, viele Unternehmen versuchen es jetzt und sagen, okay, wir brauchen keine...
So was, ja, so was, okay, so was hat es mir gefallen.
Ja, aber es gibt ja viele Unternehmen, die sagen, ey, wir wollen keine Junior-Entwickler mehr haben, macht alles AI.
Ich glaube, das geht nach hinten los auf kurz oder lang.
Ja, Support hat eh keiner Bock drauf.
Wobei man das sagen muss, ich hatte hier schon im Stream, an einen im Stream kann ich mich erinnern,
der hat gesagt, er macht das richtig gerne, Support.
Er sucht auch wieder einen Support-Job.
Chatgear arbeitet bei euch einer irgendwie so im First Level Support oder sowas und sagt, das ist das Beste überhaupt?
Also einen hatte ich hier schon mal im Stream.
Schon ein bisschen her, kann ich mich aber noch genau dran erinnern.
Wie gesagt, Beste und er sucht auch wieder einen neuen Job.
Es gibt Leute, die telefonieren einfach auch gerne.
KI Support ist richtig nervig.
Es gibt Leute, die mögen das, mit anderen Leuten zu telefonieren, sich auseinanderzusetzen.
Ja, das kann...
Leute, ich kann mir das auch nicht vorstellen, dass es so Leute gibt.
Aber die gibt's.
Ich bin auch froh, dass es überhaupt noch welche gibt, die das machen, ja.
Aber ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Aber es gibt es wirklich Leute, die machen das gerne, ja.
Okay.
Also so viele Support-Fans haben wir hier nicht.
Ah ja, ist doch nice.
Ist doch gut.
Ich finde, das soll jeder das machen, worauf er Bock drauf hat.
Ja gut, im First Level Support gibt es eigentlich kaum Anerkennung, oder? Da gibt es eher Gemecker.
Wie Krankenpfleger nur in der IT. Hat gewisse Parallelen, ja?
Also das ist ja auch sowas, ne? Ich sehe das ja bei meinem Vater, wie der immer rumstreitet und rummeckert bei seinen Pflegern.
Also, das würde ich nicht machen wollen.
Aber mein Vater ist eh sehr nervig und nicht sonderlich umgänglich.
Also der ist ja die ganze Zeit immer am Leute beleidigen und sowas.
Ist er, ist er auch, ja.
Ich habe euch ja schon ein paar Sachen erzählt
An wie viel arbeiten eigentlich First Level Supporter richtig?
Ich würde sagen die ganze Zeit, oder?
Wenn viel los ist, ruft da laufend jemand an
So, schauen wir mal, was können wir uns auf YouTube heute angucken
Was verdient IT-System-Elektroniker?
Bam, das gucken wir jetzt
Elektroniker
Elektronikers
Toss, toss, toss, toss.
Moment.
Was war das gerade?
Das hat er doch überhaupt nicht gesagt.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Übersetzt es mir gerade ein deutsches Video auf Deutsch?
Oder, ach Moment, oder ist das
Ist das Zeichensprache und die übersetzen uns das?
Ja!
Das ist Gebärdensprache, die übersetzen uns das.
Ach so, ah jetzt.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr was?
Ich habe mittlerweile schon gedacht, es ist AI-Übersetzung.
Soweit sind wir schon auf YouTube.
Ich habe gedacht, er übersetzt mir ein deutsches Video in deutsche AI-Übersetzung.
Chat.
SlimTrain fragt, ich muss mal eine Frage stellen.
Was ist eigentlich mit Admins in Deutschland los?
Die Spanne von Fähigkeiten ist so extrem.
Ich habe richtig krasse Typen, kenne keinen richtigen Nullnummern.
Ja, das ist so.
Aber das ist eigentlich immer so.
Aber beide haben einen Job.
Bin erst zwei Jahre dabei.
Ja, ja, das ist normal.
Das ist normal.
Also meiner Meinung nach ist es so,
dass 80, 90 Prozent der Leute
schlecht bis ganz okay sind
und nur 10 Prozent der Leute richtig Plan haben.
Aber es gibt auch genug Aufgaben für Leute,
die ganz okay sind,
weil vieles ist halt einfach nur Routine-Kram
oder so 0 nach 15-Kram,
wo du jetzt gar nicht großartig Ahnung haben musst.
Und die haben auch Jobs, ja.
Aber so richtig Leute mit Plan gibt es vielleicht 10%.
Genau.
Das ist auch eine Erfahrung, die ich gemacht habe.
Die Leute, die wirklich Ahnung haben und richtig gut in dem sind,
Die interessieren sich zumindest meistens auch privat für diesen Kram. Für die ist das auch jetzt nicht wirklich ein Job, wo sie morgens hingehen und sagen, ich mache jetzt hier halt meine Arbeit und wenn ich heimgehe, dann gehe ich zum Mai eine Runde Fische fangen oder sowas.
sondern die sagen, ey, ich habe da was gesehen oder letztens ein Konferenztalk gehört dazu,
ich starte heute Abend bei einem Minikube und probiere irgendwas Neues Kubernetes-mäßiges aus
oder da gibt es ja so eine neue Terraform-Alternative, lass mal Crossplane ausprobieren oder sowas in der Richtung.
Also die sind da halt durch und durch so drin, weil sie eben das persönlich interessiert.
Kein Job? Wieso arbeitest du Teilzeit?
Hä?
Kein Job? Was meinst du mit kein Job?
Ach, du meinst, weil ich eben gesagt habe, für die ist das kein Job?
Nee, nee.
Was ich meine ist, für die ist das nicht so...
Ja, nee, weil das nicht so ist wie, sagen wir mal, wenn du jetzt irgendwas machen müsstest, wo du nicht richtig Bock drauf hast, ja, was für dich quasi nur ein Job ist, wo du sagst, okay, ich gehe jetzt an die Wursttheke und muss da Wurst verkaufen, so.
Hast eigentlich keinen Bock drauf, machst es aber trotzdem, weil du Geld dafür kriegst.
dann wirst du nicht auf die Idee kommen, dich außerhalb der Arbeit
dich noch irgendwie mit Wurstverkäufen zu beschäftigen
wenn du allerdings jemand bist, der privat mega interessiert ist
an Technik XY oder irgendwie gerne selbst programmiert
oder gerne neue Sachen ausprobiert, gerne bastelt, was auch immer
Heimautomatisierung betreibt oder sonst was
dann ist das halt nicht ein reines
ich mach das jetzt auf der Arbeit und wenn ich heimkomme, denke ich da nicht mehr dran
sondern das, was er auf der Arbeit macht, ist halt das, was ihn auch persönlich interessiert.
Und das in Kombination sind halt meistens auch die Leute, die richtig krass Plan haben.
Das sind dann auch Leute, die auf irgendeine Konferenz gehen und da,
oder das haben wir mal, vielleicht nicht unbedingt, das stimmt nicht wirklich,
aber das sind dann Leute, die sich beispielsweise abends noch Konferenztalks angucken.
habt ihr schon verstanden, aber das kann bei manchen so wirken,
man muss ein totaler Freak in einem Thema sein,
sonst ist man nicht super sein und ein Megaplaner, das ist auch so.
Wenn du nicht persönlich für dieses Thema dich wahnsinnig interessierst,
wirst du nie zu den Top-Know-How-Leuten in dem Gebiet gehören.
Du kannst auf der Arbeit dich viel mit auseinandersetzen und auch viel lernen,
aber wirklich so hier Peak-Ahnung haben, ist nur, wenn es dich persönlich interessiert und dich auch aus persönlichem Antrieb mit neuen Sachen beschäftigst.
Wie viele Sachen ich schon ausprobiert habe, bevor das jemals relevant auf der Arbeit geworden ist, kann ich gar nicht mehr zählen.
Und ich habe auch genug Sachen ausprobiert, die nie relevant geworden sind auf der Arbeit.
Das heißt nicht, dass man 24-7 nichts anderes mehr machen kann.
Man sollte sogar noch ein bisschen was anderes machen, aber ich merke es beispielsweise oftmals in der Richtung. Wenn mich ein Thema gerade richtig krass interessiert, dann ist es so, dass ich mich teilweise aktiv dagegen entscheiden muss, da jetzt weiterzumachen.
Ja mal angenommen, ich bin gerade dabei irgendwie, ich lerne gerade eine neue Programmiersprache oder ich probiere gerade irgendwie was aus und bin dann gerade voll im Hackerman-Modus und voll am Basteln und ich stelle fest, Mist, es ist ja schon 19 Uhr, keine Ahnung, gearbeitet bis 15.30 Uhr, dann ein bisschen hier weitergebastelt und ich stelle so, oh es ist ja schon 19 Uhr, du müsstest jetzt ja eigentlich mal rausgehen, dich noch eine Runde bewegen oder sowas.
Da muss ich dann erstmal aktiv sagen,
nee Max, jetzt hör mal auf damit,
auch wenn du gerade voll da drin bist,
jetzt hör doch mal auf damit
und geh noch mal eineinhalb Stunden raus
oder geh mal deine 45 Minuten
rennen oder sowas. Ich muss mich dann wirklich aktiv
davon teilweise losreißen,
weil ich jetzt eigentlich weiter basteln will.
Ja.
Also du hast recht, also du solltest nicht nur 24-7 das machen.
Man hat oftmals so die...
So das Bedürfnis, das ist es eigentlich.
Du hast das Bedürfnis irgendwie so innerlich vom Antrieb her,
24-7 dich damit zu beschäftigen und das zu machen,
weil es eben das ist, was dich persönlich auch am meisten interessiert.
Aber du solltest es nicht machen.
Ja.
Ja, das ist doch auch vollkommen okay.
Das ist doch vollkommen auch okay.
Man muss auch schon ein bisschen drauf achten, wie es einem persönlich so geht. Ich sage nicht, dass man das machen sollte, wenn man keinen Bock drauf hat. Aber es kann auch genauso gut Erholung für einen sein, wenn man sich neben der Arbeit, also mal angenommen, ich musste jetzt auf der ganzen, machen wir mal ein Beispiel, was ich von mir kenne.
Ich musste den ganzen Tag auf der Arbeit irgendwelches Terraform-Zeug zusammenwurschteln und kann es nicht mehr sehen. Dann habe ich abends die Auswahl zwischen, ich spiele ein bisschen MMO oder ich bastle an meinem Microcontroller-Projekt weiter.
mal mache ich das, mal mache ich das
aber es kann auch durchaus
im Kopf entspannend sein
sich mit IT Sachen zu beschäftigen
die einen persönlich
sehr interessieren, die jetzt aber nicht
sagen wir mal
100% da so Überlappung
mit der Arbeit haben, also wenn ich den ganzen
Tag
Terraform Zeug gebastelt habe auf der Arbeit
dann werde ich mich höchstwahrscheinlich nicht
mehr hinsetzen abends und gucke mir
das neueste Terraform Changelog an und gucke,
wie man das noch anders machen kann. Das würde ich nicht machen.
Aber ich kann mich abends hinsetzen
und beispielsweise an meinem Microcontroller-Projekt
weiterarbeiten.
Das ist für mich dann auch Entspannung.
Oder aber ich setze mich hin und spiele eine Runde
MMO oder irgendwas anderes.
Und wenn du das Gefühl hast, ey, du brauchst
mal was ganz was anderes abends,
dann ist es auch sinnvoll, das zu machen.
Also sobald man sich irgendwie dazu
zwingen muss, zu sagen, ey,
ich mache das jetzt, dann hat es ja mit
Erholung auch nichts mehr zu tun.
Ja, das ist bei vielen,
das ist in vielen Unternehmen so, ja.
Dass du ein paar hast, die richtig
krass Plan haben und ein paar, die halt die
anderen Sachen so machen. Da muss ich echt mal
eins sagen, bei uns, also bei
mir im Team, würde ich sagen, ist
der Anteil, ich weiß auch nicht, wie sie das machen,
aber das spricht für meinen Chef, ja,
oder für die Chefs, ist der Anteil
der Leute, die Plan haben, relativ hoch.
Würde ich echt sagen.
Also auch im letzten,
also auch beim letzten Arbeitgeber
würde ich auch sagen, hatten wir bestimmt
gut die Hälfte der Leute, wo ich
sagen würde, Alter, die haben richtig Plan.
Und jetzt würde ich sogar noch einen Schritt
weiter gehen und sagen,
jeder
hat Plan, aber halt nicht von allem.
Aber das
habe ich auch nicht.
Ab wann darf man sich Hacker nennen,
wenn du drei verschiedene Arten kennst,
Wim zu beenden?
Chat.
Drei verschiedene Arten, Wim zu beenden.
Wer fängt an?
Wim.
Drei verschiedene Arten. Auf geht's.
Wer sagt die erste?
Alter, vier geht nicht.
Okay, Chat, ihr habt's schon. Ist schon gut.
Steuerung O. Steuerung O kenn ich noch nicht.
Steuerung O ist Nano, oder?
Ja, Steuerung X ist hier.
Aber, Chat, ihr habt's schon.
Ihr habt's schon. Ist schon alles gut.
ZZ geht.
Q geht. WQX geht.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ich habe doch schon habe ich doch schon
fresher frog habe ich doch schon
wie ist das denn teilzeit
habe ich schon gibt es gibt
ja hier guck mal warum die vier tage woche einfach besser ist mein fazit nach zehn jahren teilzeit
arbeiten alternativ gibt es hier noch ein video teilzeit aber in die beste entscheidung
also da habe ich schon ein paar sachen zugemacht
und jetzt aber das video 1 gucken
gehalt und beruf in der qualitätssicherung
dass wir den monitor für herz opfers verbaut die müssen ganz exakt funktionieren ja das
kann ich mir vorstellen wer blöd wenn die einfach an der falschen stelle schnippeln
ok chat wir müssen das noch mal rüber schützen immer wenn es questions gibt max wie ist deine
erfahrung in bezug auf renn und danz im team ist die aufprallend dass wenn man heute auf
morgen jemand nicht mehr da ist kann kein jobwechsel dass keiner mehr im thema drin
Oder ist das...
Was?
Und das ist das Team?
Ja, es gibt immer Themen, die sind...
sind...
nur bei einem im Kopf.
Also man versucht natürlich, zumindest bei uns ist das so,
dass offiziell hat jeder so eine Vertretung irgendwie,
aber wenn es dann wirklich in die Details geht,
ist man schon bei manchen Themen aufgeschmissen.
Ja, das ist so.
Man bemüht sich quasi schon, dass jemand zweites Ahnung hat.
Aber es gibt immer so Detail-Sachen, die weiß dann...
Da denkt man auch gar nicht so dran.
Die merkt man dann erst, wenn derjenige gerade mal nicht da ist.
Ne, die Reaktion ist, dass wir das schon probieren.
Dass es überall jemanden gibt, der sich auch noch mit auskennt.
Aber wie gesagt, man denkt an diese Sachen gar nicht unbedingt. Das sind Sachen, die merkst du erst, wenn derjenige nicht da ist. Zum Beispiel, es gibt bei uns so eine Software, die letztendlich verschickt dir eigentlich nur Dateien. Von A nach B.
So, das ist aber so eine super alte, obskure Software mit merkwürdiger Config, die ein bisschen aussieht wie Ini-Files, wo dann da steht von diesem Verzeichnis, wenn da was reinkommt, soll das dahin geschoben werden und sowas in der Richtung. Ganz altes, outdatedes, obskures Zeug und das ist ein kleiner Teil von einem größeren Service.
und letztens hatten wir zum Beispiel mal das Problem,
dass derjenige,
der sich halt mit diesem einen Teil
auskannte, nicht da war.
Und irgendjemand hat dann bei uns
wahrscheinlich eine E-Mail geschickt,
nicht angerufen, eine E-Mail geschickt,
irgendwie Transfer von den und den
Files würde nicht funktionieren,
von einem Partner zum anderen und sowas.
Und da haben wir uns erstmal angeguckt,
haben gesagt, wie Moment, das gibt's überhaupt?
Also, dass es das gibt, habe ich schon mal gehört, aber keine Ahnung. Das sind so Dinge, da denkst du eigentlich gar nicht dran. Das sind so Teile, die laufen da seit 15 Jahren und gehen eigentlich immer. Die merkst du erst, wenn derjenige mal nicht da ist, der Ahnung hat und an dem Tag was ist.
Man kann sich, man wird dann nie 100% abdecken können.
Man kann sich Gedanken zu machen, dass jeder beispielsweise mal aufschreibt, so nach dem Motto, was hat er denn für Themen, wo er denkt, dass die für sowas relevant sind.
Aber so 100%ig wirst du das wahrscheinlich nicht vermeiden können.
In der Arbeit gibt es nichts zu tun, was wir uns beschäftigen.
Guck dir beispielsweise Konferenztalks an, über Themen, die dich interessieren.
Ansonsten gibt es jede Menge.
Du kannst auch den ganzen Tag auf Reddit chillen und gucken.
Wenn es nichts gibt.
Ich gucke mir gerne
Konferenztalks an.
Wenn nichts zu tun ist.
Aber das kommt selten vor.
das wirst du auch gar nicht hinkriegen man das gehirn ist kein raid 1 du kannst das gehirn nicht
raid 1 von einem zum anderen das wird immer lücken geben immer kannst da kannst du nichts dagegen
machen ganz versuchen dass es so wenig wie möglich probleme gibt aber alles hundertprozentig abfall
es geht nicht so als kurzes video fertig wir haben schon ganze neun sekunden davon geguckt
Leute. Okay. Das heißt, wenn ich einen Fehler finde, dann müssen wir echt Gas geben. Dann
haben wir Zeitdruck. Ja. Im ganzen Umland gibt es nur eine Dolmetscherin. Guckt ihr euch irgendwelche
lötstellen an oder wie? Lohnt sich das?
Hallo ich bin Pascal Kleimeyer. Ich bin 36 Jahre alt und arbeite als Qualitätssicherheitsbeauftragter
im Qualitätsbereich für elektronische Bauteile von klein bis groß. Diese Teile sind für den
medizinischen Bereich, für Flugzeugtechnik und so weiter.
Aha.
Woche.
Das war kacke.
Ich möchte selbst den Fehler finden, wie bei einem Puzzle. Wenn ich keinen Fehler finde, dann ärgert's mich fast.
Das ist halt meine große Motivation.
Ich will den Fehler finden und im nächsten Schritt die Ursache rauskriegen.
Also suche ich nach dem Warum.
6 Uhr.
Ohne diesen Mantel kommt man hier nicht rein.
Da ist eine elektronische Kontrolle am Eingang.
Diese kleinen elektrischen Schläge kennt man ja, wenn man etwas anfasst.
Das sollen diese Mäntel verhindern.
Ah.
Und wie genau sollen die das machen?
Also interessiert mich echt, wie so ein Mantel elektrische Schläge verhindern kann.
Den zieh ich mir auch an.
Die sind leitend. Ja, aber wohin leiten die?
Die hängen doch in der Luft.
Ach so.
Ja, nee, man steht ja auf dem Boden, ne?
Oder wie? Oder was?
Erstmal Teams aufmachen.
Scheint schon ein bisschen...
Wenn ich hier hinten den Osterhasen sehe,
scheint schon ein bisschen älter zu sein, ne?
Das kann ich lesen, meine Antworten schreibe ich dann.
Für mich ist diese Firma ganz besonders.
Vor allem wegen meiner Arbeitskollegen.
Sie verstehen und unterstützen mich sehr.
Und behandeln mich nie wie einen Außenseiter.
Keiner denkt, dass ich etwas nicht kann, nur weil ich gehörlos bin.
Die Firma hat mir gerne die Chance gegeben,
in diesen Beruf als Qualitätssicherheitsbeauftragter innerhalb des Hauses zu wechseln.
Davor habe ich in einem anderen Bereich hier in der Firma gearbeitet.
Dieser Beruf jetzt ist komplizierter. Es ist viel Kommunikation notwendig.
Wir kommunizieren über Handy, chatten, schreiben schnell mal was auf.
Die Kollegen gestikulieren. Sie kennen mich inzwischen und wissen, wie sie mit mir umgehen müssen.
Der kann bestimmt sehr schnell tippen.
Sauf. Anzahl offenes Sauf. Und Anzahl überfälliges Sauf.
Das werden wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Tickets sein oder sowas.
Auffälligkeiten? Sicherheitsauffälligkeiten oder sowas?
Was könnten Sauf bedeuten?
3 Uhr 30, da kannst du aber...
Das ist ja wirklich 3 Jahre kein Leben gehabt, ey.
Da bist du ja mal richtig im Arsch.
Vor allem 2,5 Stunden fahren,
2,5 Stunden, das ist ja krass, ey.
Gucken, vielleicht erfahren wir noch, was Saufs sind.
Übrigens, ich finde es auch nice, dass die über die Hälfte Anzahl überfälliger Saufs,
man kennt es, mit Ticketfälligkeitsdatum und sowas.
Jetzt bin ich fertig.
Alle offenen Mails sind abgearbeitet und es ist 8 Uhr.
Das ist meine typische Frühstückspause.
Aha, gibt ne Kantine.
Leberkäs!
Excellent!
Erstmal ein schönes Leberkäsbrötchen.
Zu dringenden Terminen ist es schwierig Gebärdensprachdolmetscher zu bekommen.
Hier im ganzen Umland der Firma gibt's leider nur eine Gebärdensprachdolmetscherin, die
allerdings auch nicht immer verfügbar ist. Hier braucht es einfach mehr Dolmetschende.
Für mich ist es ideal, wenn bei wichtigen Terminen eine Dolmetscherin dabei ist. Wenn
das nicht klappt, nutzen wir alternativ auch MS Teams. Meine Kollegen und ich sehen uns
via Bildschirm und alle gesprochenen Inhalte werden als Untertitel angezeigt.
Ich bin froh, dass wir auf der Arbeit Teams haben und nicht irgendwie Zoom oder Slack oder so ein
Krempel. Und ich kann mitlesen. Der Nachteil ist nur, dass ich darauf nicht so schnell antworten
kann, weil ich ja erst tippen muss.
Aber mir ist vor allem wichtig,
dass ich alle Informationen mitbekomme,
um gut mitarbeiten zu können.
Wir haben gerade besprochen,
dass... Also für sowas kann ich
mir, wie der Chat sagt, für sowas kann ich mir
in Zukunft
das richtig gut vorstellen, dass du sowas
von KI machen lassen kannst.
Ein neuer
Auftrag noch heute fertig werden muss.
Es geht um einen Kunden aus der Medizin.
Teams ist so ein Schmutzprogramm.
Was ist denn die Alternative? Mir geht Teams auch oft auf den Sack.
Aber was ist die bessere Alternative zu Teams?
Discord.
Webex! Boah, nee, hör mal bloß auf.
Bei ISC wäre ich dabei.
Ich soll jetzt Stichproben nehmen und prüfen, ob alles in Ordnung ist.
Fax, Leute, Fax. Fax ist die einzig wahre Alternative.
Wenn ich einen Fehler finde, dann müssen wir echt Gas geben, dann haben wir Zeitdruck.
Mein Kollege und Chef hat mir gerade gesagt, dass das ein echt wichtiger Auftrag ist.
Ich soll genau schauen, ob alles passt, vor allem, ob richtig gelötet wurde.
Am Rücken achte ich also ganz genau darauf, weil die Baugruppen zum Beispiel später in Monitore für Herz-OPs eingebaut werden.
Die müssen absolut zuverlässig funktionieren. Da darf nichts beschädigt oder fehlerhaft geliefert werden. Das wäre echt schlecht für uns.
Der Lötschamp.
Deshalb müssen wir hier sehr sorgfältig Stichproben machen, damit der nächste Bereich ohne Probleme weiterarbeiten kann.
Mein Spezialbereich ist die optische Kontrolle. Das passt gut zu mir und liegt mir einfach.
Ich schaue mir die Bauteile entweder unter dem Mikroskop oder im Röntgenbild an und kann Fehler erkennen.
Ja wie, was ist denn das? Das ist ja mal ein Beitrag, wo einer tagsüber auf was arbeitet.
Ich nehme die Bauteile direkt in die Hand und scanne sie mit meinen Augen sorgfältig ab.
Wenn ich einen Fehler erkenne, melde ich das sofort.
Wie fett sind eigentlich diese Karten, ey? Vor allem, das sieht ja aus wie Hardware von 1985.
Mega, mega fett.
und ob das Bauteil richtig zusammengesetzt wurde.
Man sieht hier zum Beispiel die Punkte, das sind Lötstellen.
Ja.
Ob die jetzt ordentlich aussehen können, ich habe das nicht beurteilt.
Und in diesem Fall ist alles in Ordnung.
Ja, das ist ja von unten, das darf er zeigen, aber von oben darf er nicht zeigen.
Ich schaue mir aber auch die umliegenden Bereiche an,
um sicherzustellen, dass die elektronischen Verbindungen korrekt sind.
Hier passt alles. Puh.
Jetzt muss ich dasselbe auch bei den Steckern machen.
Also schauen, ob immer vier schwarze Punkte, die Lötstellen, auch da sind.
Schaut.
Aha. Lötstellen sind da.
Alle da, alles in Ordnung.
Es wird aber schon langweilig mit der Zeit, oder?
Die zweite Stichprobe sieht auch gut aus. Es passt alles und ich kann alles zurückgeben.
Super.
Das ist ein Job, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass ist was, wo sie später wahrscheinlich
versuchen werden, das durch KI zu ersetzen.
Ob's klappt, ist wieder was anderes.
Ich hab den nächsten Auftrag.
Kommt mit.
Beim Fehlermessen gibt's mehrere Möglichkeiten.
Wenn zum Beispiel eine Maschine 1000 Teile produziert und ein Fehler auftaucht,
muss ich erstmal prüfen, ob das nur ein Einzelfall ist oder ein serienmäßiger Fehler.
Wenn es nur einmal vorkommt, naja, das kann mal passieren.
Aber wenn es ein Serienfehler ist, dann muss ich natürlich herausfinden, woran es liegt.
Man sieht hier, dass das so Wellen macht und sich immer wieder abhebt.
Eigentlich müsste das ganz flach aufliegen, also wirklich planen.
Was sehe ich denn da gerade?
Es wurde als Teil einer Baugruppe geliefert, kam aber fehlerhaft zurück.
Es liegt nicht flach auf. Es steht immer wieder ab. Und jetzt soll ich herausfinden, woran das liegt.
Ob der Fehler an diesem Teil hier selbst liegt oder vielleicht schon bei der Lieferung etwas schief gelaufen ist.
Und das muss ich jetzt rausfinden.
So Mikroskope sind bestimmt schweineteuer.
Aber Chat, ich gebe euch recht, es macht bestimmt Bock, wenn man da so ein Faible für Hardware-Elektronik-Kram hat.
Aber ich denke mir halt so 50 mal das gleiche Teil kontrollieren, das wird dann schon langweilig.
Was stand da gerade?
Der Chef muss den Test genehmigen.
Na dann.
Das müssen wir auf jeden Fall machen.
Ganz genau.
Man sieht schon, dass das ein kritischer Fehler ist.
D.h., ich muss das einem Kollegen übergeben.
Der wird einen Lötsinntest machen.
Damit kann man rausfinden, woher der Fehler kommt.
Ich gebe das also jetzt weiter.
Wir hatten einmal den Fall, wo wir bei uns ein Projekt hatten,
was wir seit Jahren mitfertigen, wo es sehr wenig Probleme gab.
einen schlag sind zwei baugruppen den test mit ausgefallen die mitarbeiter haben es erst einmal
nicht gemerkt nur anhand des testergebnisses werden dann pascal zur unterstützung gestellt
der hat sich eine baugruppe in die hand genommen hat die so ein bisschen hin und her geschwenkt
und konnte uns dann genau an der stelle sagen dass oben links innerhalb des gehäuses eine schraube
gefehlt hat und das war für uns genau dieser punkt wo wir gesagt haben das ist der hammer
dieses Feingefühl, was er hat, was wir eigentlich kaum hören konnten, hat er wirklich gespürt und das Gehäuse aufgeschraubt.
Es war genau so, wie es er uns gesagt hat.
Ist das ein Playstation-Controller? Nee, oder? Habe ich mich gerade verguckt?
Ah nee, das ist ein Barcode-Scanner und eine Maus.
Ich hab das irgendwie, mein Kopf hat da irgendwie so ein Ding draus gemacht und ich hab gedacht, da liegt ein Playstation-Controller.
Also wenn ihr da so schepp drauf guckt, könnt ihr nachvollziehen, was mein Gehirn da gemacht hat?
Okay, nicht, naja.
Mein Wunsch ist natürlich, dass ich den Fehler zuerst selber finde.
Aber wenn ich gar nicht weiterkomme, dann muss ich es ans Analyse-Team übergeben.
Die haben verschiedene Messtechniken, mit denen sie alle Bauteile und Verbindungen prüfen können.
Auch Dinge wie USB und so weiter. Die messen dann so lange, bis sie den Fehler gefunden haben.
Püüüüt. Ah, die teuren, die teuren Multimeter.
Meine Ausbildung zum IT-Systemelektroniker habe ich bei einer hörenden Firma gemacht
und parallel dazu die Berufsschule für Gehörlose in Essen besucht.
Das war mein erster großer Schritt in die hörende Welt und das war am Anfang ziemlich
herausfordernd.
Vor allem die Kommunikation.
Ich musste erst lernen, wie ich mit Hörenden am besten kommuniziere und habe verschiedene
Strategien ausprobiert und viel gelernt.
Damals war alles schwieriger ohne technische Hilfsmittel wie Apps zur Kommunikation.
Es gab oft Missverständnisse.
Viele Kollegen waren nicht so zufrieden mit mir.
Heute ist das ganz anders.
Die Technik hat sich stark verbessert und auch die Zusammenarbeit läuft viel besser.
Ich bekomme viele Chancen und viele geben sich wirklich Mühe.
Ich kann hierbei...
Da musst du aber auch in der richtigen Firma landen.
...barrierefrei arbeiten und fühle mich dabei wohl.
IT-Hausmeister.
Was macht man als IT-Hausmeister?
Turnschuh-Admin oder...
Geschäftsstelle...
Was?
Ach, Taube.
Was? Taube? Dreisen? Def? Traffel?
Anlagenbedienung?
Jetzt ist Mittagspause. Hier gibt es immer gutes Essen. Da freue ich mich schon. Kommt!
Erstmal in die Kantine.
So ähnlich läuft das bei uns auch.
Wir haben auch so eine Karte, wo man in die Kantine kann.
Bei uns gibt es auch zu ermäßigtem Mitarbeiterrabatt in der Kantine.
Da kann man für 7 Euro
kann man Hauptgericht, Salat und Nachtisch sich holen.
Das ist wirklich preis-leistungsmäßig,
kann man da gar nichts dagegen sagen.
Das ist echt nice.
Und was zu trinken ist auch noch dabei.
Schickst du auch immer den Azubi, dass er mit Rabatt dein Essen holt?
Nee, mach ich nicht.
Ich geh da einfach selbst hin.
Chat, was habt ihr da im Chatkarten mit Let's Encrypt?
Was, wie?
Also ich weiß ja nicht genau was es hier geht.
Also was geht ist, du kannst bei Let's Encrypt kannst du DNS, diese DNS Authentifizierungs
Geschichte machen.
Dann brauchst du keinen Server, der im Internet steht.
Aber ich habe jetzt nicht so genau gecheckt, um was es hier geht.
So, gucken wir jetzt erstmal fertig.
Das hier sind kleine elektronische Bauteile.
Sie werden auf die Platine gesetzt und fest verlötet, damit alle Verbindungen richtig funktionieren.
Guck mal, ein Button ist da drauf.
Ich zeig's euch.
Ach, SMD, oder?
Surface Mounted...
Wofür steht denn das D in SMD eigentlich?
Die weiß!
Die weiß.
Okay.
Da hätte ich selbst drauf kommen können.
Hier zum Beispiel sieht man die Stelle, wo die elektrische Verbindung hergestellt wird.
So kann der Strom fließen und das elektrische Signal weiterlaufen.
Der Widerstand spielt dabei eine wichtige Rolle.
Wenn irgendwo ein Fehler oder ein Defekt entsteht, so schützt der Widerstand die Schaltung, damit andere Bauteile nicht kaputt gehen.
Darum braucht es diesen Schutz, damit alles zuverlässig funktioniert.
Hier kann man das gut erkennen. Alles ist in Ordnung und sauber verbunden.
Hier gibt es viele verschiedene Baugruppen und Bauteile.
Unsere Kunden kommen aus der ganzen Welt und bestellen ihre Baugruppen hier bei uns.
Einige Produkte sind geheim, zum Beispiel Bauteile, die in der Raumfahrt oder speziellen Projekten verwendet werden.
Die dürfen wir nicht zeigen.
Ich bekomme im Monat fast 3500 Euro brutto.
Das ist auch von den Leistungsprämien abhängig, also im Sommer und im Winter.
Das ändert sich.
Ist jetzt aber nicht so krass viel.
Je nach Leistung eben.
Netto sind es im Schnitt
2395 Euro.
Schönen Abend zusammen.
41k, das ist ja
nicht so geil.
Hallo.
Geht's dir gut? Ja.
Hallo ihr zwei.
Spiele ich gerade Fortnite? Ah ne, die gucken auf dem Handy.
nebenberuflich bin ich gelegentlich als gebärdensprachdozent tätig falls ein
anderer dozent zeit und interesse für diese wobei leute eigentlich war das
richtig boomer von mir oder keiner in dem alter spielt heute mehr fortnight
die spielen alle roblox wir hatten letztens 22 praktikanten aus der schule
und ich habe die richtig boomer mäßig gefragt ob heute noch fortnight gespielt
wird da meinten die ja manche spielen das noch aber die meisten spielen das
nicht und irgendwie ist roblox von minecraft auch nicht mehr roblox ist
voll angesagt kann ich nicht nachvollziehen ehrlich gesagt aber tja
anscheinend ist das so ich habe auch letztens irgendwo gelesen das meist
gespielte Spiel 2025
oder 2024
war irgendein Roblox
Mod oder irgendein
Roblox Game.
Irgendwas
mit Garten oder so.
Irgendwas mit Garten.
Garten bauen in Roblox oder so.
Das war irgendwie das meistgespielte
Spiel 2024.
Crow My Garden, ja das kann sein, dass das so hieß.
Da verstehe ich dann die Welt nicht mehr.
Aber ich bin jetzt 41.
Ich darf die Welt auch nicht mehr verstehen.
Das ist okay.
Ach so, übrigens.
Es gab jetzt...
Es gibt, weil jemand sagt Plants vs. Zombies.
Es gibt jetzt ein Plants vs. Zombies.
Das wollte ich mir eigentlich mal angucken.
Ein Remake.
Mal gucken, wie die... Mixed-Bewertung.
Okay. Warum sind die Bewertungen
mixed?
Was wurde hier wieder verkackt?
Was wurde da wieder verkackt?
Ist komplett Trash, leider. Echt? Warum?
Och nee, oder? Ich hab mich da echt
gefreut drauf. Hätten wir gerne wieder gespielt.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal.
No reason to blame this playlist over the game of the earth.
The new content...
The drama leading up to the release.
Was ist denn da schon wieder passiert?
habe ich auch nicht mitgekriegt
...
Scheint doch nicht so toll zu sein,
aber okay.
So, schauen wir jetzt noch fertig.
Noch 30 Sekunden.
Habe ich das Falsche aufgemacht?
Ja, ne, ne.
Das meinte ich doch.
Das kam gestern raus.
Reisen gehört auch zu meinen Leidenschaften.
ordentlich ich brauche ein einfaches gutes leben viel geld ist für mich nicht das wichtigste
hauptsache aber es schadet auch nichts wenn meine familie ist glücklich dass es uns gut geht es
geht darum dass wir uns schöne dinge leisten können ausflüge urlaube ausgehen gemeinsam mit
der familie zeit aber mit 41 k mit der ganzen familie das wird aber weiß nicht so große sprühe
kannst damit ein Szenario machen.
Was erleben? Dann bin ich zufrieden.
Ein Luxusleben brauche ich nicht.
Ein ganz normales Leben reicht mir völlig.
Ja, gut, das verstehe ich auch.
Luxus brauche ich auch nicht.
Ja, war zur Abwechslung mal einer,
der tatsächlich den ganzen Tag was geschafft hat.
Sachen gibt es.
Huch, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Das gucken wir uns nicht heute an.
Den Vortrag wollte ich mir schon die ganze Zeit mal angucken
Aber das geht 30 Minuten oder so
Das gucken wir nicht heute
Das Spiel und Zeug Video hat man noch
Ja, richtig
Ja, das da
Eure übertriebenen Smart Homes
Was die Leute wieder heimautomatisierungsmäßig gebastelt haben
Ja, richtig
Du solltest dort mal mitmachen
So viel tolles zu zeigen gibt es bei mir
jetzt Smart Home technisch nicht.
Das coolste, was ich eigentlich zeigen kann, ist meine
Heizung.
Ne, das coolste,
was ich zeigen kann, ha, doch,
eine Sache habe ich, die ist cool.
Also die würde wahrscheinlich
wirklich in so einem Video gut
drankommen.
Die
Das Ventil im Keller.
Das haben wir doch sogar im Stream zusammengebastelt.
Wobei, ich glaube, im Stream hat es nicht funktioniert.
Okay, was auch immer.
Ich glaube, im Stream hat es nicht funktioniert.
Und zwar, wir hatten doch hier...
Heizung...
Smartventil, genau.
Hier hatten wir es doch.
Genau.
Und zwar, da gibt es...
Hier sieht man das Ding.
Was nicht so einfach ist.
Ja, ja, Max.
Das ist übrigens nicht meine Hand.
Ja, guck, hier sieht man,
das ist so ein Motor,
Mit so einem Ding, was sich dran dreht.
Und da habe ich unten im Keller, wir haben das dann hier gebastelt, ja, hier, Bastelstelz.
Da habe ich ein D1 Mini reingelötet, mit WiFi drauf.
Und ich kann jetzt über WLAN quasi das Ding triggern und das macht im Keller das Ventil auf für Heizung, Wasserzufuhr für die Heizung, also Wasserdruck für die Heizung.
und wenn die Heizung
irgendwie, weil normalerweise
sollte ja kein Druck verlieren, aber alle paar Monate
musst du da mal kurz ein bisschen das Ventil
aufmachen, kann man einfach auf dem Tablet
drücken, dann macht es das auf
und dann kann man wieder zumachen
kann quasi wirklich, so ein Wasserhahn
kann man im Endeffekt auf und zu drehen
da mit dem Keller, das ist nice
Tipps wie ich HDMI
Switch automatisiere, also
wenn gar nichts geht, was
immer geht ist
ein Switchbot.
Also wenn
sonst gar nichts geht,
ein Switchbot geht immer.
Guck, das ist so ein Ding,
das hat hier so einen Knopf drauf.
Äh, kein Knopf, so ein Schalter dran.
Der drückt für dich Knöpfe.
So.
Ah ja, ist doch nice.
Dann musst du nicht in den Keller.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Das kannst du auch machen.
Den E-Switch habe ich mir noch nicht überlegt.
Was passiert beim Stromausfall?
nix da wenn der strom wieder da es geht er halt an wieder der motor der motor
springt nicht an automatisch beim stromausfall oder beim strom wieder
angehen
ach so meinst du das du meinst wenn der gerade offen ist und der strom ausfällt
ja dann bleibt das ventil offen das ist so das richtig gut da passiert ja dann
auch nichts also wenn der gerade wenn man wirklich gerade das offen hat und in
dem moment wo in den fünf minuten wo man das offen hat der strom ausfällt dann
bleibt es ventil offen aber sobald der strom wieder da ist kann man sie wieder
zu machen
Bekommst du mit, falls es nicht reagiert?
Ja.
Das mache ich ja nicht automatisch.
Ich drücke ja auf meinem Tablet
auf den Knopf
und wenn es nicht reagiert,
man hört das.
Das rauscht so in der Heizung.
Und wenn ich zumache und es rauscht
immer noch, also man hört beim zumachen schon,
dass es dann so
beim zumachen und dann hört man, dass es aus
und es piepst danach auch nicht mehr und rauscht nicht mehr.
Ich kriege es aber auch mit, weil ich habe einen Live-Feed aus dem Keller von der Druckanzeige.
Ich kann mir die Druckanzeige von der Heizung angucken, während ich das anhabe.
Ich habe da eine Webcam, die hat den Nachtsichtmodus an und filmt die Druckanzeige von der Heizung.
Da kann ich direkt zugucken, bis das dann auf 2,8 ist und bei 2,8 schalte ich aus.
Ich habe ein Wall-Display für HA.
Ich habe ein altes Fire HD 10.
Und im Keller irgendein billiges Samsung-Tablet an der Wand im Flur.
Welche Webcam hast du?
das ist eine wise cam mit custom firmware die habe ich vor jahren mal
gekauft
so ein ding ist das mit custom firmware github
Äh, nee.
Das ist es nicht.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Aber die gibt es, glaube ich, nicht mehr.
Dustin, danke schön für den Sub.
Okay, schauen wir uns mal an, was andere Leute so in ihrer Heimautomatisierung automatisiert haben.
Moment.
Moment, ist das ein Mülltonnenversteckungsding?
Das ist ja auch Next Level.
Da gehen sogar die Deckel hoch.
Okay, das ist ja albern genau.
Albern weggeballert.
Morgen, KS.
Sehr gut.
Heute ist es wieder soweit.
Wir schauen uns an, was ihr bei euch zu Hause alles smart gemacht habt.
holen uns dabei Inspiration, Unterhaltung und vielleicht ein bisschen Kopfschütteln.
Menschen, Tiere, Automation, los geht's.
So macht Müll ausbringen Spaß.
Tobias, das will ich sehen.
Zwölf Jahre lang standen unsere Mülltonnen einfach so neben dem Haus vor der Garage.
Scheiße, meine Mülltonnen stehen auch einfach neben der Garage.
Ich glaube, es wird Zeit, Leute.
Ich glaube, es wird Zeit.
Hier muss demnächst dringend was automatisiert werden.
Jeden sichtbar, ein Schandfleck.
Das muss sich ändern.
Natürlich kann man sich auch einfach eine fertige Mülltonnenbox kaufen.
Wie viel kostet da eine Box für die Mülltonnen?
Natürlich.
1200.
Ist die vergoldet oder?
Kann man sich auch einfach eine fertige Mülltonnenbox kaufen.
Allerdings fanden wir die preislich nicht ganz so attraktiv und überzeugend.
Alter, ist das teuer.
davon passt eine fertige box eh nicht in die nicht rechtwinklige ecke vor unserer garage
glück gehabt würde ich sagen doch bevor es los ging musste erst mal ein plan her denn planung
ersetzt bekanntlich zufall durch irrtum aus holz sollte es sein mit schicken rombusleisten vorne
zwei türen um die mülltonne für die wöchentliche lehrung wieder rauszufahren oben eine öffnung um
den rausgebrachten müll schnell zu entsorgen begrüntes dach und dinge von oben in die tonne
werfen das widerspricht sich doch aber tür öffnen mülltonne herausziehen deckel öffnen
müll einwerfen deckel schließen mülltonne wieder rein schieben tür wieder schließen
wie ging ganz schön umständlich und überhaupt eine ganz normale mülltonnen box ohne stromanschluss
ohne wifi okay nicht ins smart home integrierbar ja also die mülltonnen box die braucht dringend
WLAN sehe ich auch so. Excuse me? Wir haben 2025 schon unser alter Opel aus 2009 hatte
eine elektrische Heckklappe. Wieso sollte ich also die Mülltonne von Hand öffnen?
Berechtigte Frage. Realisiert habe ich das Ganze mit einem höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Ja das ist ja eine geile Idee.
Das ist ja mit dem Schreibtisch, da musste erst mal drauf kommen. Das ist Pfeifett.
Wichtig war, dass er einen großen Höhenverstellbereich bietet, möglichst viel Last trägt und außerdem eine schnelle Fahrgeschwindigkeit bietet.
Zudem sollte es möglich sein, den Schreibtisch nicht über das Bedienpanel, sondern über einen ESP32 anzusteuern.
Das ist glücklicherweise bei den meisten Modellen von Flexispot der Fall.
Moment, Flexispot kann MQTT? WTF?
Da hier schon jemand das Protokoll reverse engineered.
Ach nee, nee, okay.
Geil.
Alter!
Also, wisst ihr was, was ich mir gedacht hätte?
Ich habe ja auch einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch hier.
Der hat aber nur zwei Knöpfe hoch und runter.
Warum auch immer man da irgendwie zehn Knöpfe oder so braucht.
Das könnte man einfach mit, wenn man das aufmacht,
könnte man das einfach mit irgendeinem Relay schalten.
Also quasi den Button Press simulieren.
Vorinstallierte Höhen, ja, da hast du recht. Stimmt.
Weil er für den Einbau zu groß war, musste der Schreibtisch an einigen Spots noch mit der Flex bearbeitet werden.
Vermutlich auch daher der Name Flexi-Spot.
Kleine Herausforderung war, einen Regenablauf für das Pflanzbecken zu realisieren.
Der Stopfen an der Tischplatte fährt nun in das Elektroinstallationsbord und schließt den Passablauf.
In der Mülltonnenbox selbst habe ich einen Potest angebracht,
so dass die Tischplatte des Schreibtisches im eingefahrenen Zustand bündig mit der Oberkante abschließt
und die maximale Öffnungshöhe im voll ausgefahrenen Zustand erreicht.
Die Box lässt sich über einen Taster öffnen und schließen.
Das ist schon nice irgendwie, oder?
Übrigens von diesen Knöpfen habe ich auch welche hier.
Wo ich den gerade sehe.
Öffnen und schließen.
Da dies jedoch nichts für Ungeduldige ist, habe ich auch in der Küche unter der Spüle einen ZigBee-Button montiert,
mit dem man die Mülltonnenbox öffnen kann, wenn man den Müll rausbringt.
So ist die Box bereits offen, wenn man dort ankommt.
Das ist natürlich der große Vorteil, wenn man das Ganze irgendwie in seinem System...
Ich meine, das ist so eine typische Automatisierung, wo man sagen muss,
braucht eigentlich keiner so wirklich, aber trotzdem richtig nice.
Und sehe ich da etwa auch eine LED-Unterboden- oder Deckelbeleuchtung?
Alternativ kann man die Öffnung auch durch ein Sprachkommando an eine beliebige Alexa im Haus triggern.
Außerdem habe ich eine LED-Beleuchtung verbaut, die sich beim Öffnen und Schließen automatisch zu- oder abschaltet.
Vergisst man die Mülltonnenbox wieder zu schließen, gibt es nach 5 Minuten eine Erinnerung.
Die Mülltonnenbox ist noch offen.
Gesteuert wird das Ganze über einen ESP32.
Diese Boxen kann ich übrigens auch sehr empfehlen für Elektronik-Krams.
die sind ip 56 glaube ich und die kosten nur 70 cent oder so bei amazon
ich habe davon auch eine ganze menge allerdings nicht in schwarz sondern in
grau verteiler
äh,
heute habe ich wieder eine andere
Postleitzahl, äh,
Verteiler
Dose,
nicht Steckdose, Dose,
genau, sowas hier,
boah, Alter, ja, hier kommen wir
der Sache schon näher, ne, EP54 sind die,
ja,
guck, das geht klar, kostet 8 Euro,
kriegst
10 Stück,
7 fach 12 die die anschlüsse
9 euro auch ein bisschen teurer geworden
immer gucken teilweise gibt es die echt gibt sie echt günstig
und die eignen sich so für elektronik sachen
richtig vor allem kannst du hier durch diese durchführung auch super kabel und so durch machen
Alternativ noch mit so einer Durchführung kannst du sogar wasserdicht hier durchführen
die Kabel, so zum verschrauben auf beiden Seiten.
Also die Dinger sind sehr praktisch für Elektronikbastelkabeln.
...Controller, welcher über MQTT mit meinem OpenHub Server verbunden ist.
Der ESP ersetzt somit einfach das Bedienpanel, welches normal mit der Steuerbox verbunden
ist.
Noch ein paar Worte zu dem Mechanismus, der die Deckel der drei Mülltonnen hochzieht.
Ziel war es, dass sich die Deckel der Mülltonnen bereits so früh wie möglich öffnen.
Natürlich noch eine Simulation.
Doch, eine habe ich noch.
Warum hat er eine Simulation davon?
Da der ESP32 schon mal da war, hat er nur noch eine Zusatzaufgabe bekommen.
Direkt neben der Mülltonnenbox werden nämlich unsere beiden Autos aufgeladen.
In die Ladeklappen habe ich Bluetooth Low Energy Beacons eingeklebt.
Der ESP misst nun die Empfangsstärke zu den Bluetooth Beacons und so kann ich jederzeit sehen, welches Auto gerade an der Wallbox steht.
presence detection fürs auto das ist ja mal pfeifett
und meine ladestatistiken in evcc weiß nun endlich das korrekte fahrzeug aus was über
die hersteller apps leider nicht immer zuverlässig funktioniert. warte mal das sieht ja das sieht ja
also hier sieht man dass die autos offenbar getauscht sind oder hier ist das blaue auto
weg. Das ist ja albern genau.
Das ist der Unterschied.
Das ist mega.
Welches Auto gerade an der Wallbox steht.
Und meine Ladestatistiken in EVCC
weisen nun endlich das korrekte
Fahrzeug aus, was über die Hersteller
APs leider nicht immer zuverlässig funktioniert hat.
Mit dem Gesamtergebnis bin ich recht
zufrieden und die Box hat mittlerweile
auch ihren ersten... Ja, auch recht zufrieden.
Ganz okay. Kann man so lassen.
Das ist richtig nice, was er da gebaut hat.
Winter unbeschadet überstanden.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen soll.
Tobias, das war mal wieder
sehr gut. Ich habe
eigentlich große Lust, das Ganze direkt
nachzubauen, vor allem, weil meine Frau mir gerade
eröffnet hat, dass sie einen anderen
Schreibtisch möchte. Also so gesehen ist
das... Wisst ihr, was mir gerade
noch einfällt, Leute? Wenn die
Mülltonne zu voll ist und
der Tisch dann runterfährt, das ist ja
fast schon eine halbe Kompresse noch, weil
so ein Tisch, der drückt auch ordentlich drauf.
Kannst du deinen Müll noch
komprimieren?
Vermutlich bald einer über. Der kleine Wermutstropfen bei mir ist allerdings, dass mein Mülltonnenplatz aktuell noch so aussieht und gerade ganz andere Probleme hat.
Aber ich werde das im Kopf behalten. Ich habe Pläne für den vorderen Bereich, aber das ist alles. Das wird alles zu teuer.
So, Feuerwehrautomation von Johannes. Schauen wir mal rein.
Als Mitglied einer freiwilligen Feuerwehr besitze ich so einen digitalen Melder.
Wenn der liebst, muss ich möglichst schnell zum Feuerwehrhaus kommen, weil ein Alarm ist.
Um mir dabei das Leben etwas zu vereinfachen, habe ich mir ein paar Automatisierungen eingerichtet.
Die Idee ist folgende.
Wenn der Melder losgeht, geht das Licht hier im Schlafzimmer an.
Dann drücke ich auf diesen roten Knopf hier, um quasi zu bestätigen, dass ich da bin und zum Einsatz fahren werde.
Wenn ich den Knopf also drücke, geht unten schon mal der Rollladen an der Terrassentür hoch und das Licht wird aufgesperrt.
Das Licht geht auch überall im Haus an, wo ich dann langlaufen werde.
Zusätzlich wird für mich in unserem Feuerwehr-Internen-System zum Einsatz zugesagt und übermittelt, wie lange ich brauchen werde.
Dank dieser Abläufe verliere ich im Alarm solche Keinigkeiten.
Licht einschalten, Rohrladen hochfahren oder die Tür aufschließen, passiert alles automatisch.
Das ist besonders nachts, da sind die Rohrladen und die Tür in der Regel zu und ich müsste sonst erst im Halbschlaf an der Terrassentür stehen und warten, bis sich langsam alles öffnet.
Aber durch die Automatisierung läuft das alles schon, während ich noch schneller aus dem Bett komme und mir zügig etwas Anständiges anziehe.
Sämtliche Automatisierungen und Abläufe werden zentral über meinen Home Assistant Server gesteuert.
Die Erkennung des Alarms wird über einen ESP32, der an zwei Pins der Ladestation von dem Pager angeschlossen ist.
Bei Alarm schaltet in der Ladestation ein Relais, das diese zwei Pins elektrisch miteinander verbindet.
Das wird dann durch den ESP32 erkappt.
Okay, das ist schön zuverlässig.
Benutzt der ESP Home, hä?
ESPHome ist sowas, da bin ich immer noch kein...
bin noch nicht richtig damit warm geworden.
Ich bastel da lieber selbst die Firmware komplett.
...und mittels ESPHome an den Server geschickt.
In dem roten Knopf daneben steckt auch ein ESP32,
der im Prinzip genau den gleichen ESPHome-Code laufen hat.
Für den Terrassentürteil des Systems nutze ich einen Nuki Smart Lock
und einen EVE-Rollladenschalter.
Das Nuki wird von Home Assistant über MQTT angesprochen.
Der EVE-Schalter ist aber aufgrund von fehlendem Meta-Support
über ein paar Umwege mittels Thread über Apple HomeKit integriert.
Die Zusage im Feuerwehrsystem ist ein einfacher Request an die API von dem Service, den wir nutzen.
Um zu sehen, wie schnell das System im Alarmfall reagiert,
habe ich jetzt ein paar Tage abgewartet, weil heute Probealarm ist.
Und das wäre...
Wir haben den Probealarm gezeigt.
Werden wir gleich sehen.
Düüü.
Okay.
Sehr cool. Also wir hatten tatsächlich lange keine Feuerwehr- und Einsatzautomation mehr, nachdem wir anfangs gefühlt in jeder Folge was hatten. Aber du hast es tatsächlich schön gelöst. Und neben der Tatsache, dass du einfach durch diesen Buzzer-Druck dein Haus vorbereitest, außerdem ist ja das Zusagen, das automatisch passiert, wenn du sagst, ja, ich nehme diesen Einsatz an, eine Sache, die auch keine Zeit mehr braucht.
Also du musst ja im Prinzip nur noch aus dem Bett auf dein Fahrrad fallen oder womit auch immer du dann zur Wache kommst.
Aber das sah schon ziemlich gut aus.
Und jetzt müssen wir vielleicht mal zusehen, dass wir Eve dazu bekommen, eine Metafirmware für die Rollladensteuerung zu bringen.
Wenn du mit deinen Sachen bei dir zu Hause was Schönes automatisiert hast, dann schick es mir gerne unter zeug.coolslash zeigen.
Und alle gezeigten Einsendungen bekommen wie immer einen 50 Euro Amazon-Gutschein.
Und dabei hilft uns heute xCloud, der günstigste Premium Cloud Speicher und Backup Anbieter. Ich nutze xCloud schon seit dem Start meiner Netzwerkfestplatte, beziehungsweise mit hervorragendem Support und ganz ohne Risiko im Test. Vielen Dank xCloud, dass ihr dieses Video möglich macht.
So nice, das ist so frickelig und gebastelt, wie du es machst im Endeffekt.
Aber es ist deutlich einfacher geworden insgesamt, muss man sagen.
Also Home Assistant unterstützt ja mittlerweile auch irgendwie gefühlt 3000 Sachen.
Und dadurch, dass du keine oder weniger YAML-Configs brauchst als früher,
und mehr über das Web-UI geht, ist es auch einfacher geworden.
Aber es ist letztendlich immer noch komplex und frickelig.
Ein bisschen davon abhängig, was du machen willst.
Es ist eigentlich so komplex und frickelig, wie du es machst.
Heute ist offenbar große ESP-Sonderfolge hier.
Patrick hat uns was zu seinem Auto geschickt.
Wie viele von euch?
Ich habe auch ich zu Hause einen Home Assistant,
der sich um meine Automationen kümmert.
Wie hat er denn die Kamerafahrten und so gemacht?
Hat er einen extra Kameramann dafür?
Manchmal ist man nicht so.
Also man ist nicht in seinen eigenen Flirrwänden.
Man möchte Automationen, die auch funktionieren, wenn man mal nicht zu Hause ist.
So wie ich heute in der Natur und jetzt gerade zufällig am Meer.
Und gerade hat das Auto einfach hinter mir abgesperrt.
Und der Grund ist, ich habe mich entfernt.
Und das Gleiche funktioniert natürlich auch andersrum.
Das heißt, wenn ich mich wieder dem Auto nähere, dann sperrt es mir im besten Fall wieder auf.
Und das einzig und allein, weil es mein Telefon erkennt.
Ich habe also eine Automation gebaut, die mir ähnlich wie Nuki Türen öffnet und in dem Fall im besten Fall...
Naja...
Ich weiß nicht...
...sogar erlaubt, das Auto zu starten und einfach damit wegzufahren.
Erzähl mir mehr.
Und wenn dir einer das Smartphone klaut?
Und das klappt hervorragend und ich brauche keinen Autoschlüssel mehr.
Wie das geklappt hat, zeige ich euch jetzt.
Na gut, den Autoschlüssel kann ja auch einer klauen.
Voraussetzung dafür ist natürlich ein Start-Stop-Knopf, so wie dieser hier, also ein Keyless-Go-System.
Also einfach mal Schlüssel aufschrauben, wahllos Kabel dran löten und einen ESP32 damit verbinden.
Und am Ende des Tages verschiedenste AI-Tools wie Codex...
Also bei meinem Fiat drücke ich einen Knopf, dann geht die Tür auf und dann schmeiße ich den Schlüssel in die Mitte.
von diesem, wie nennt man das?
Rechts neben dem Sitz.
Mittel, Mittelfach oder so.
Mittelkonsole.
Schmeiß ich das rein und dann lässt er sich starten.
Gemini oder Claude Cote fragen.
Claude?
Schreibt mir bitte den Code dafür.
erklär mir bitte, wie ich das anstecken soll und warum sind Widerstände manchmal sinnvoll?
Nach einigen Wochen habe ich es hinbekommen, dass mein Prototyp funktioniert hat.
Um die letzte Frage noch zu beantworten, woher kommt der Dauerstrom für den ESP2?
Lass mich raten, vom Licht? Ich würde jetzt einfach mal sagen, vom Licht?
Glücklicherweise liefert mir die...
Okay, direkt über dieses Debug-Interface.
Okay, ja.
Die OBD2-Schnittstelle in jedem modernen Auto.
Dauerstrom.
Und ja, es gibt auf Amazon OBD2 zu USB-C-Kabel,
die mir hierfür weitere Kabeleien erspart haben.
Wieder was gelernt.
Ich wusste nicht, dass es OBD zu USB-C-Kabel gibt.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich müsste in meinem Auto ja erst mal einen Kabel bauen zu ODB.
Das ist wirklich wild.
Also, ich meine, wenn die Autohersteller zu blöd sind, das zu liefern, was wir alle haben wollen,
dann machen wir uns das halt selbst mit Blackjack und Home Assistant.
So, Ronny.
Ich habe immer mal vergessen, die Garage zuzumachen und damit ich das mitkriege,
habe ich hier einen Shelly-Sigbee-Kontakt.
Das Gegenstück klebt da oben.
Und das meldet mir dann einfach über Home Assistant,
wenn ich mein Garagentor vor länger als 10 Minuten offen gelassen habe und ich nicht.
Ja, das ist was Einfaches und Praktisches.
Zuhause bin. Damit ich das aber auch ändern kann, also dass das Garagentor dann auch aus der Ferne zugemacht werden kann,
habe ich hier hinten Licht, Steckdose und hier ist ein Taster, der macht mein Garagentor zu und auf.
Der geht natürlich auch noch. Und das habe ich aber verbunden mit einem Shellid.
Ich klaue mir hier drüben von der Steckdose den Strom. Hier, das geht zu meinem Schalter. Das ist das Tor von meinem Nachbarn.
Das sieht aus, als wärst du die perfekte Zielgruppe für meine neue Unternehmensausstattung für
professionelle Elektrikerfachbetriebe wie dein.
Im ersten Schritt gibt es zum Beispiel dieses Arbeitsshirt in der gewohnten Qualität aus
meinem Shop, alles irgendwie Siebdruck.
Und damit du noch besser arbeiten kannst, gibt es auch die Stabila Electric, die perfekte
Wasserwaage um Steckdosen, also ohne 230V, sagen wir Netzwerkdosen, perfekt gerade einzubauen
andere Dinge zu installieren. Die hat hier hinten so eine kleine Kante und hier unten
einen Magnet, wo du die auf die Dose aufsetzen kannst und die perfekt ausrichten.
Auch das natürlich mit dem passenden Unternehmensbranding. Alles jetzt
auf Zeug.shop zu haben. Entschuldigung, ich musste das mal kurz hijacken.
Kleiner Sellout am Rande muss sein.
Jetzt muss ich mich hier mal eben wieder einjacken. So, weiter geht's.
Im Gegensatz zum Auto, das hier drin steht, ist die Lösung nicht ganz so fancy.
der shelly kann ja potenzial frei schalten deswegen kann ich darüber einfach aus der ferne
die diesen taster betätigen kann mein garagentor zu machen kann das ganze auch über was macht der
knopf taster betätigen aus der ferne alles gut aber was warum hast du den knopf daran geht es
sind erweiterungen im android auto steuern also kann im display drücken und dann habe ich außerdem
Gibt es eine Home Assistant App für Apple Car?
Oder CarPlay?
Aha.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Es geht...
Ach, man kann die Home Assistant App
auf...
auf einem Car Playdings?
Das muss ich machen?
Das ist schon praktisch.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich weiß gar nicht genau, was ich überhaupt schalten möchte vom Auto aus.
Egal, aber das brauchen wir.
Den Taster, den Input, noch abgekoppelt vom Shelly.
Das heißt, wenn ich mit vollen Einkaufstaschen jetzt rein möchte, ist meine Haustür noch zu.
Und ich kann aber kurz diesen Taster hier drücken.
Und jetzt?
und dann entriegelt das hier die Tür.
Wenn der Summer gebrummt hat,
dann hat das durch den Gummi von der Tür
so eine leichte Vorspannung.
Deswegen kann man hier einfach dagegen drücken,
kommt in den Hausflur rein
und hier kommt man
zur Wohnungstür.
Wohnungstür gibt es so ganz billige Tuya-Dinger
mit Fingerabdruck
und für die Tür.
Da hätte ich, also ganz ehrlich,
Smart Locks
kommen mir nicht ins Haus.
bin ich überhaupt kein Fan von.
Unten
gibt es hier so ein
Ring-Intercom an so einer
Siedleranlage. In Home Assistant
da kann man in der App,
in der Companion-App, in Android Auto
da kann man das Garagentor
als Favorit hinterlegen, sodass man das
im Android Auto in der entsprechenden App
ganz oben hat. Das ist ja wild.
Wie sicher ist denn dieses Tuya-Schloss?
Das sieht so ein bisschen aus, als würde das einfach
über einem von außen steckenden Schlüssel sitzen.
Das kriegt man nicht irgendwie einfach abgezogen oder einfach mit ausreichend viel Kraft einfach gedreht, auch wenn der Fingerabdruck nicht aufschließt?
Oder ist das ein eigener Zylinder?
Schreibt es gerne mal in die Kommentare, wie das Ding funktioniert, weil so bin ich erstmal ein bisschen ängstlich und ich habe eigentlich keine Ahnung, was smarte Türschlüsse angeht.
Dominik hat irgendwas hier am Pool gemacht, das heißt Reiergart.
ich weiß nicht ob es irgendwas mit vpn zu tun hat wir werden jetzt musik das leben noch ein paar
fische das war ja gar die geht es darum dass der reihe die fische nicht abholt abholt rauspickt
habe ich mir mal hier gerade wissen was zusammengebaut zwar eine kleine automation
aus dem bewegungsmelder der ist da hinten und die pumpe die gesteuert wird über die
wird der reiher verschreckt
geile idee
Und dann geht's hier zweimal an und dann wird er verschreckt.
Das ist nicht geil.
Beste.
Er hat mal weggeballert, den Fischreier.
Das finde ich sehr interessant.
Das ist eine coole Sache.
Vor allem, ob das langfristig funktioniert.
Wir hatten früher auch einen Fischteich im Garten.
Und dann wurde Anfang der 90er Jahre ein Fluss in Bremen verlegt.
Und plötzlich hatten wir andauernd Fischreier im Teich stehen.
Ziemlich bald mehr als...
Ich hatte mal Enten auf meinem Teich hinten im Garten.
die haben sich irgendwie verirrt
und sind dann mal einen halben Nachmittag rumgeschwommen.
Und das hat der Katze nicht gefallen.
Weißt du auch, die hier war das noch.
Moment hier, die da, die Katze.
Die ist dann den Garten hinter und hat die Enten gesehen
und hat sich nicht mehr in den Garten getraut
und ist dann vorgekommen zu mir in den Hof
und hat im Hof erst mal Krach gemacht,
dass ich mal gefällig dahinter gehen soll
und die Enten vertreiben soll.
Sie selbst wollte das nicht.
Habe ich aber nicht. Ich habe gedacht, die hauen schon wieder ab und die sind dann auch abgehauen.
Allerdings hatten meine Eltern auch nicht die Möglichkeiten der Heimautomation zur Verfügung.
Dominik, bitte berichte, wie sich deine Lösung im Alltag schlägt oder geschlagen hat.
Ob du die Fischreihe alle in den Teich geblasen hast.
So, damit haben wir ja auch Tiere abgehakt.
Sehr gut. Gleich noch mehr Tiere.
Wir haben auf unserem Grundstück leider ein paar Mitbewohner, die wir nicht eingeladen haben.
Und nachdem sie meiner Mama die Blumen aus dem Blumenbeet gefressen haben, war es Zeit, Maßnahmen zu unternehmen.
Ne, was sind das denn?
Was sind das? Sind das Ratten?
In super aufgeräumten Schuppen haben sie sich auch breit gemacht und ich habe mir dann überlegt, was ich machen kann.
habe ein bisschen in meiner Schublade gekramt und habe dort noch eine WLAN-Steckdose und eine kleine Kamera gefunden.
Mit Hilfe derer habe ich dann eine kleine Automation erstellt.
Und wenn die Ratten sich jetzt hier bewegen, dann wird die ausgelöst.
Ich triggere den Bohrhammer.
Und in der Tat sind seitdem...
Da hauen die ab, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Keine Ratten mehr aufgetaucht.
Vielleicht, weil die ein bisschen Angst vor dem Dien-Gor haben, den du hier aufgebaut hast.
Den Bohrhammer mit dem Kabel in so einer Beige da rumballern zu lassen.
Bist du dir sicher, dass das Kabel nicht anknuspert?
Oder die Beige zaballert?
Ansonsten finde ich so eine Idee ganz spannend.
Wir scheinen nämlich jetzt auch ein paar Mitbewohner im Garten zu haben,
die wir nicht eingeladen haben.
Das könnte auch eine wilde Spielwiese der Aufrüstung sein.
An dieser Stelle auch nochmal der Hinweis aufs Menschentier.
Da freuen sich die Nachbarn bestimmt, wenn der Bohrhammer nachts um vier angeht.
... Automationen nachsitzen. Das sind Automationen, die ihr eingesendet habt, die vielleicht ein bisschen zu lange oder ein bisschen zu speziell sind, um sie hier in dem Video breit zu treten, um von YouTube nicht komplett unter den Teppich gekehrt zu werden.
Und dieses Mal hat Markus seine Wärmepumpe smart gemacht. Wenn ihr in eurer Funktion finanziell unterstützender Kanalarbeiter dieses YouTube-Kanals seid, stehen euch die Türen dazu offen.
Wenn nicht, geht es jetzt weiter mit Till. Der hat eine Kühlschranktür nicht gegen den Kopfballer-Automation gebaut.
Moin Andreas, wir hatten da so ein kleines Problem in der Küche, wo ich mir mit einer klitzekleinen Automation geholfen habe.
Und zwar ist es so, wenn die Kühlschranktür offen ist, schlägt die Küchentür gegen die Kühlschranktür.
Hakt da auch noch der Türgriff dahinter? Das sieht nach keiner guten Kombination aus.
Nachdem ich jetzt das dritte Mal die Kühlschranktür gegen den Kopf bekommen habe, als ich was aus dem Kühlschrank geholt habe,
habe ich hier oben einen Fensterkontakt befestigt.
Und wenn ich die Kühlschranktür aufmache, geht dann ein rotes Licht vorne an oder irgendwie sowas?
Und fängt hier draußen im Flur eine Lichtleiste an, rot zu leuchten und signalisiert der Person, die die Küche betreten will,
dass sie vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz warten sollte.
Und wenn die Kühltraumtür wieder zu ist, ist der Weg wieder frei.
Sehr schön. Also tatsächlich, wenn ich so drüber nachdenke,
sollten Türrahmen vielleicht einfach pauschal indirekte LED-Beleuchtung eingebaut bekommen.
Ist ja auch an Toilettentüren sinnvoll.
So ein leuchtendes Rot, wenn die besetzt sind.
Achtung, sitzt gerade einer drauf.
Und vielleicht ein Gelb, wenn sie zwar theoretisch frei sind,
die Luft aber noch nicht einmal wieder umgewälzt wurde oder so.
Ich wollte hier eigentlich einen Anker-Solix-Smart-Meter einbauen lassen, aber jeder Elektriker, den ich gefragt habe, hat mir gesagt, nein, dieser Zählerschrank ist älter als Methusalem, da muss ein neuer rein.
In der Zwischenzeit möchte ich aber trotzdem meine Balkon-Kraftwerkanlage smart machen und bei meinen Recherchen bin ich dann auf dieses schlaue Gerät gestoßen, den IOMeter.
Hier war nämlich gar nicht bewusst, dass man seinen Zähler freischalten lassen kann mit einem Pin.
Ja, wenn man so einen neuen Zähler hat. Ich habe ja immer noch diesen Ollen mit der Scheibe drin.
Diese optische Schnittstelle mit diesem Gerät, das Auslesen und das sogar ohne Stromanschluss über das WLAN.
Und diese Daten von meinem Echtzeitverbrauch bekomme ich dann nämlich in Home Assistant.
Dann springen wir ins Dashboard in Home Assistant.
Ah, Star Wars.
Ich habe auf der rechten Seite die aktuelle Leistung der vier Solarpaneele.
Ich weiß was es ist, ich wollte ein paar Leute von euch triggern.
Es gibt immer das ist so...
Mal sehen wie viele Kommentare sich trotzdem unten angesammelt haben.
Von Leuten die entrüstet in der Zwischenzeit.
Das ist kein Star Wars, das ist Star Trek.
Ja da regen sich die Leute auf.
Batterie, Ladestand. Hier unten ist der aktuelle Hausverbrauch, der geliefert wird von IOMeter und der wird einmal die Minute aktualisiert.
Die Automation stellt sicher, dass möglichst immer der Hausverbrauch abgedeckt wird.
Primär natürlich aus aktueller Leistung, sekundär aus der...
Warum sind die 330 Watt eigentlich so pixelig? Gehört das auch zum Star Trek Design?
Und dass die Einspeisung immer Gen 0 geht mit verschiedenen Einstellungen, die sicherstellen, dass es nicht so oft fluktuiert und nicht bei Kleinständerungen jedes Mal wieder umgestellt wird, sondern nur bei relevanten Veränderungen im aktuellen Hausverbrauch.
Das gleiche hatten wir ja im Prinzip vor kurzem, als wir bei Marc die Balkonsolaranlage aufs Dach gebaut haben. Das Video findet ihr oben. Er hatte einen etwas neueren Zählerschrank, sodass die Installation eines Smart Meters da drin weniger ein Problem war. Aber das so auch in einer älteren Umgebung nachzurüsten, für den kleinen Heimelektriker sicherlich eine gute Lösung.
Also wenn man zum Beispiel einen größeren Verbraucher anschaltet wie eine Mikrowelle oder was ähnliches. Diese Daten kann man natürlich auch für andere Automationen weiterverwenden. Zwei Beispiele bei mir. Ich habe einen Kellerraum, der gerne mal etwas feuchter wird.
Das heißt, wenn gerade Leistung übrig ist und der Akku bereits voll ist, kann man die aktuelle Leistung dazu verwenden, hier den Entfeuchter einzuschalten und laufen zu lassen.
Und das Schlafzimmer ist bei uns im Nachtgeschoss. Da wird es im Sommer auch gerne mal etwas...
Mein Keller, der hat so eine hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit, da müsste ich nur entfeuchten die ganze Zeit.
Da kann man die Energie für die Klimaanlage nutzen, die dann schon mal den Raum ein wenig vorkühlt und dass wir so klima- und möglichst kostenneutral diese Geräte betreiben können, wenn noch Reserven aus der Sonne kommen.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Sache. Das ist ja auch eine Form des Energiespeichers. Also ich kann meinen Pufferspeicher überhitzen, aber auch sowas, Keller entfeuchten, Schlafzimmer vorkühlen, sind super Lösungen, wirklich, ja weiß ich nicht, über den Betonteil bei euch zu Hause, ein bisschen von der überflüssigen Energie, die ihr habt, sinnvoll für einen guten Zweck zu verbauen.
nice sachen dabei auch stromverbrauch mit stil hergestellt hast dann schicken wir gern davon
ein kleines video unterzeugt punkt kurz lässt zeigen wie gesagt 50 euro für jede im video
verwurstete automation vielleicht schicke ich da wirklich mal unten meinen wasserhahn auf und zu
drehen dingen hin just for fun dann kann man sich demnächst angucken falls das nimmt
Hast du meinen Kommentar zu Solar gesehen?
Nee.
Max, wenn du die Scheibe hast, musst du Solar aufs Dach machen.
Dann zählt der auch rückwärts.
Ja, aber ich mach mir kein Solar.
Also erstmal nicht aufs Dach.
Aber dann sonst noch hier.
Das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
GTF.
Was war mit Karsten?
Leute, irgendwas stimmt nicht.
Ah, die Zeitumstellung.
Weil ich hab Hunger.
Und es ist erst 11.30 Uhr.
Irgendwie ist das komisch.
Aber ja, das passt ja, wenn
Zeitumstellung
heute gibt es keine nudel mit lachs heute gibt es nudel mit currysoße und hackfleisch
Gucken wir mal, ob es noch neue Package Updates gibt.
Wir haben jetzt schon eine Viertelstunde nicht mehr aktualisiert.
Nein.
Geht denn hier das wieder?
Ah ja.
Package Tracer hat ja nicht funktioniert.
Mach ich mal aus.
Kann nichts versprechen.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Z-Servers hat ja mittlerweile 75 oder so.
75 Übungen.
Wir haben 76 sogar.
Eigentlich ziemlich hog.
Battlefield 6?
Nee.
Kann auch gerade nicht.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Okay.
Chat, ich hab Hunger. Ich geh jetzt versetzt.
Mir egal, ob es erst 11.30 Uhr ist.
Vielleicht, vielleicht...
ja vielleicht gucke ich noch irgendwie serie oder so eine halbe stunde und dann
dann gehe ich was wird dann
ich habe jetzt ab und mittag weiß ich noch nicht
was schaust du bin mir sicher vielleicht gucke ich auch eine runde
war schon hast du schon battlefield 6 videos gesehen ja eine ich habe auch
schon battlefield 6 streams geguckt es wirkte auf mich tatsächlich ein
bisschen wie 20 42 so von vom feeling her aber vielleicht täuscht das auch
Was schaust du?
Was ich gerade geguckt habe, ist
Secrets of the Silent Witch
heißt das, glaube ich.
Habe ich irgendwie die ersten drei Folgen geguckt, ist aber irgendwie noch nichts passiert.
Hat aber gute Bewertungen.
Ist das...
Das ist...
Aber sowas von
Ah ja, ja.
Ohne den Bullshit
Ja, das ist schon mal nicht schlecht
Alles klar, Leute
Ich geh jetzt
Off
Vielleicht bis später
Aber wahrscheinlich eher nicht
Guck mal mal
Bis dann, macht's gut, see you